Hello dirty freaks,
Jess,
you are shut up.
Stop.
Get over it.
It's just a label.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by ting.
What's Tang?
Joe Ting is a cell phone service that cuts out all the bullshit that you have to
deal with with most cell phone services like contracts.
There's no contracts with Tang Tang sets it up smoothly and easily.
So if you want to fucking bail,
you just bail sun.
Most of the time when you get a phone from a,
um,
a major provider,
what you're doing when you buy a phone for like 200 bucks,
the phone really probably costs like 500 bucks or more.
But what you're doing is you're paying for the phone,
sort of like on layaway.
So if you go home,
quit and your phone service sucks or can't make calls from my house.
When you cancel your,
I'm sorry,
I made you sound so dumb.
Just figurative.
It's not really you.
That's only me.
That's actually how I speak off there.
Yeah.
He has a weird voice off the year on the air.
He's so smooth,
but off the year just judge duper going home down.
I'm tired of fucking assholes tweeting at me.
Um,
the,
uh,
the anyway point is if you try to leave your contract,
you have to pay money.
That's not our Tang has it?
Tango has it set up where they rent time on the sprint backbone,
which sounds really fucking weird,
but just the term renting time on a backbone.
Yeah.
Um,
back points.
They'd probably come up with a new name for backbones.
Is it a sweaty backbone or is it an LTE vacuum and backbone?
It's a,
it's a computer network sort of a thing.
I don't understand it.
You know,
why,
why call it background?
Did you run out of words you can make with your face?
It's not a backbone.
I know what a backbone is.
Network network doesn't sound as cool or grid.
It does sound though.
Grid.
The sprint network is a,
uh,
you know,
major provider.
So you get major cell phone service with a company like tank with no early
termination fees,
no nonsense,
no contracts.
And here's the best part.
You pay for what you use.
That's it.
Like say if you pay,
if your cell phone costs x amount per month and you're allotted 120 minutes,
if you use less of those minutes,
you don't get any money back.
Right.
I mean you pay every month.
The same with with 10 you only pay for what you use.
It's beautiful.
So there's no overage fees,
there's no like,
you know,
you don't get charged like a penalty.
He does pay for what you use.
It's very simple.
It's not confusing.
And they have the latest and greatest in android cell phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy s five which just came out this week and it's quite
dope malicious.
In fact,
it's waterproof.
It has a fucking fingerprint sensor and it has a heart rate monitor on it.
Yeah,
that's pretty bad as well.
I,
I w I did a good read or read or good review about it and it said it's an
amazing phone.
You know,
it's better than the last one and stuff.
The waterproof things,
probably the best thing about it,
but they're also through so many options on this phone that it's ridiculous.
Like the fingerprint sensor.
And stuff like that.
There's so many things on this phone.
What they're doing is they're leaving apple so far behind that apple would have
to be a big fat copycat in order to catch up when they start putting things like
heart rate monitors on phones and making phones waterproof.
This isn't the only waterproof phone.
Yeah,
there's another android phone,
the Sony Xperia,
which looks pretty fucking bad ass.
That phone is also waterproof and that phone,
um,
has some red donkey Dulles Mega Pixel camera two.
I don't what the fuck?
How's the,
how's the price of the Sony?
Cause I've liked Sony stuff,
but I feel like it's always like one and a half times more expensive than,
I haven't looked into it quite honestly.
But uh,
you know,
there's what the point of,
just to get through this commercial,
it's just,
there's so many high quality android cell phones now.
There's,
there's,
there's quite a bit,
um,
including the Samsungs,
the LGS.
Motorola is now owned by Google and they're making pretty bad ass cell phones
and they have the,
the moto x,
um,
they have that at Tang.
All the best ones.
Go to rogan.tang.com and save 25 bucks off of any of these delicious and
nutritious new devices.
That's Rogan dot Tang or bring your iPhone.
Oh,
that's right.
You can bring your iPhone to your iPhone,
especially if it's coming over from sprint.
Right.
And um,
the care of the iPhone,
you can get an iPhone five now to get it to work on Ting.
Any way.
That's the commercial,
the end Rogan,
ducting.com.
We're also brought to you by dollar shave club.
Dollar Shave Club is look my thoughts on anything that you can get shipped to
you where you don't have to go to a store.
Like,
do you know you're going to use x amount of toilet paper per month?
Yeah.
Well if you to figure out a way to get that shit shipped to you,
that's probably better than forcing yourself to go to the store all the time.
And what dollar Shave Club does is gives you a four pack for six bucks and just
sends them to you.
They have a ton of other cool things for your bathroom.
You could check out their Dr Carver's easy shave butter and a one wipe Charlies.
It's the best there.
But wives for men,
ladies and gentlemen,
and they're amazing.
It feels good.
It tingles lets you know that your butt is nice and clean.
It has aloe in it like you don't panic.
You don't panic about what your underwear look like.
Like if you're out with a chick and you decide to get freaky and you have white
underwear on,
whoa,
what a fucking crazy risk it is.
When you're pulling those bad boys out here,
you have very little idea of what you're dealing with.
Especially if you took a shit and then you sweated,
Oh,
who knows?
Who knows what kind of look.
Wiping your ass is a very inefficient way to go about your business.
It's toilet paper,
smushing shit.
All of your butthole.
That has nothing to do with dollar shave club though.
We're talking about shaving folks.
That's what's really important.
They sell other stuff,
but wipe Charlies is a really good idea,
but what's really important is saving money.
Six bucks for a four pack and get it sent to you.
That's a delicious way to go about your business.
Ladies and gentlemen,
just take care of it.
Join the thousands of guys who have upgraded the smarter way to Shave and dollar
shave club.com doesn't waste their money on ridiculous shave tech.
That's just regular four blade razors.
It's all you need.
All these nonsense fucking,
you know,
lubricated strips and special.
This relieves tension while you shapes shut the fuck up.
It does not.
It doesn't do any of those things.
There's no one throwing a glass of water on my face after I shave either.
What is that nonsense?
Why is this called the lover's blade?
Because he wants shave your ball sack with that sun.
What do you think?
If you leave the jungle down there,
you don't get as much love.
So it's a lover's blade.
It's not confusing.
Jesus Christ.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash.
Rogen.
That's dollar shave club.com forward slash.
Did they show one of those straight blades?
They don't sell those fucking things,
do they?
Cause people are just going to cut people with those pictures.
People love those things for like images,
like,
look,
here we are the old barber shop with a straight blade and a frothy.
We'll fucking whisk broom.
Let them put in the shaving cream on.
How about you just use a razor that scientists figured out you [inaudible]
and they're not that fun to get.
If you go to a barbershop and you ask to the Royal Shave,
the few times I've gotten it,
I'm in a cold sweat by the end to scared.
Just scared.
Cause it's like it's some old guy with Harry hands and he's like,
yeah.
And you hear that noise of like skin against the sharpest blade you've ever seen
and it's completely up to him to not take your life.
Right.
It's like as long as his cell phone doesn't vibrate and he's not distracted,
then you'll live to see another day or just seizes up his brain as a fucking
computer failure.
Yeah,
it just seizes up and starts doing a lot of horizontal
quantum movements with his hands slice.
Anyway,
he's getting a Shitty Yelp review if that's what happens.
Dollar shave.com Rogan.
Avoid all that stuff.
Dollar,
shave.com forward slash Rogen,
avoid it all and get awesome raisers sent to your house and you can,
no,
you can't go with six bucks for a four pack.
Come on folks.
Let's do it.
Go do it.
Click that shit.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain new mood shroom tech sport.
And what we are is essentially a human optimization website.
Um,
it's a weird word,
weird phrase to say because it doesn't really exist.
We had to make it up to describe what on it is,
but that's what it is.
We just sell you cool shit that works.
Things that help you,
whether it's help you get in better shape,
things that help your mind clear,
things that help your body recover faster,
things that help you a ingest snacks and aren't going to make you feel terrible
about yourself.
Like this new warrior bar that we just started carrying made by the same people
that made the Tonka bar just delicious.
No antibiotics,
no added hormones,
no guilt,
gluten free,
no nitrates,
14 grams of protein per serving.
And only four grams of fat and it's healthy fat,
organic buffalo meat bitch with cranberries.
It's really yummy too.
And um,
it's,
um,
it's an ancient recipe.
Apparently.
This is what they used to do with buffalo meat,
way back in the dizzy when they hadn't figured out refrigerators yet.
We're also,
uh,
caring,
um,
align of hemp force protein force protein powders and hemp force,
a protein bars and there bars that are made out of the finest hemp protein.
We A,
we buy all of our hemp protein from Canada,
unfortunately for now.
But as these laws change,
we'll talk to David Simon about this.
It seems like we're going to probably be able to,
um,
get a farm going in America,
which will drop the cost down on all of our hemp products substantially.
It's very expensive to get the highest quality hemp.
We,
we,
there's several grades that you can get.
We get the very highest grade because we doing everything online.
Uh,
we don't have a store that we send to that takes a cut out of everything.
So we can,
we can give you things in,
in the qualities and in the purity that it's like very difficult to get anywhere
else.
The combinations of ingredients,
like things like Alpha brain and people have found when they tried to do it by
themselves,
like if you want to get the same purity,
like you realize like how much it actually cost to make these things.
There's a lot of supplements that cut corners on the ingredients,
quality of ingredients.
And what we tried to do it on it is just get the very best shit available.
By default,
we don't have any economy models,
we don't have anything.
I mean the only thing that you can get cheaper than we have it with kettle
bells,
you have regular kettle bells and then the Zombie bells and the prime bells cost
more.
But that's because they're works of art and they're very difficult to recreate
everything.
Other than that,
we just go for the greatest shit that they have.
And that philosophy is sort of,
that's,
that's what I tried to do with everything in life.
I mean just what's the best air conditioner?
Get that fucking thing.
Why are you playing games?
You know,
what's the food that's the best for you?
You should probably eat that.
You know,
what is,
uh,
what's the,
what's the healthiest way to live your life go that way.
And what we sell it on it is just the best shit that we can find.
Whether it's the best organic coconut oil,
the best Himalayan salt,
the purest nutrients that we can get our hands on and the best strength and
conditioning equipment.
And if you go to [inaudible] dot com and use the code word Rogan,
you will save 10% off any and all supplements that o n n I t.com and he gigs
coming up.
Yeah,
this Friday
a Portland,
Oregon.
So Google,
we Mowgli's Saturday,
Seattle and in Vancouver for four 20 with Tony Hinchcliffe,
Tiffany Haddish test squad dot TV's on.
It is a god Damn Northwest Territory invasion.
I can't wait.
Those are three dope ass cities too.
You're going to Seattle,
Vancouver,
and Portland.
It doesn't get any better than those three places.
Yeah,
those are three of the best places on earth to perform.
Vancouver is where,
uh,
what's his name?
Eckhart Tolle.
He is from,
and that's where he sat on the park bench for a couple of years.
Really formulating all of his positive thoughts.
Yeah.
It after two years he realized that he should be in the present moment,
which is a,
I mean there's more to it than that,
but like it really took him years to fully embody like this is all I have is
this exact moment and nothing else.
Wow.
And he figured it out in Vancouver and Vancouver.
Yep.
Probably would have figured it out in Kansas.
It's bad mother fucker.
Yeah,
totally.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm thinking you can give Vancouver any credit for that even though Vancouver is
awesome.
I am at the Ice House tonight with a Ari Shaffir,
Duncan Trussell and Tony Hinchcliffe and this weekend in Orlando with Joey Dia
sold the fuck out,
bitch.
Sorry.
You snooze,
you lose.
And a next week in Baltimore with Joey Diaz probably sold out too.
If not,
there's very few tickets left.
Um,
so that's it.
Boom.
David Seaman's here.
Boom,
Sherlock log.
Boom.
All right,
now cue the music sun.
Okay.
The Joe Rogan experience
young David.
See Man is fighting crime.
That's your new song.
Yeah,
I like that.
That's great.
That's a great intro for my podcast from now and I'm just going to sample that.
Maybe a couple other things.
We were talking on the,
during the commercials about these um,
new laws that are slowly being worked in where people got allow them hemp farms
and it's,
I'm really curious to see how they handle that and woo hoo.
Who starts getting arrested were you know,
this Bundy ranch thing that's going on in Nevada and the blow back.
I know,
I know absolutely nothing about Bundy ranch.
The only thing I know about it is somebody tweeted me and said like,
why have you been silent on this?
And it's like I've been solid nine cause it's the first I've fucking heard of it
is like the other day somebody asks me,
broach the righteous indignation for you ignoring topics.
If there is a man gotten to David Seaman,
you don't want to talk about ranchers rights.
Oh,
I see where you draw the line.
It's all fine if it's drones and bitcoin.
Yeah.
I was so confused about it because I thought it was the bunny ranch the whole
time.
And I'm like,
why do they have cattle there?
That's so funny.
I saw it.
The same thing.
I,
when I saw that there was a protest at the bunny ranch,
I was like,
what happened?
I thought like maybe someone killed a prostitute or something or some horrible
thing happened or,
or they were trying to shut them down.
Someone did not get their money's worth.
So if you didn't get the price of protestors,
I was like,
leave this guy,
these guys alone,
let them just get whacked off.
Apparently it has something to do with,
um,
using land to graze cattle on and that this guy's been doing this forever and
he says that,
you know,
he's just using the land the way God intended and is all,
private or it's all public land.
And um,
the government wants grazing fees from this guy and they say that he owes the
American tax payers millions of dollars for grazing fees.
So I don't know who's right or who's wrong,
but what I do know is what they're trying to do is not handling court.
They're trying,
they're not trying to even like make a public plea for why this guy owes money.
They,
they're going there with guns and dogs and tasers and people are freaking out
and people rising up and they're saying,
hey listen,
you assholes.
When you wonder why we want to keep the second amendment,
when you wonder why we're worried about hostile takeovers and police dates.
It's shit like this.
You're talking about grass,
you fuck heads.
You're talking about cows eating grass and how you're responding.
You're responding with snipers and dogs and tasers.
Well last night I had to pick my mom up at lax cause she's visiting and uh,
on the way out the woman would not let me out of the parking lot where you'd
like pay the fee and leave and the little gate goes up.
And I was like,
what's going on here?
Like I was like,
I'll pay with cash.
Like it doesn't have to be credit card.
Like,
I just want to get the fuck out of here.
I'm tired.
My mom just got off a five hour flight,
she's tired and it's cause I have a new car.
I got a new,
uh,
it doesn't really matter.
I got a new Corolla and uh,
she's like,
says new and you don't have plates on the back.
I've got take photos of your car and get your vin number.
And I was like,
are you fucking serious?
Like how long it's going to take to write down my vin number?
Like it's dark.
You can barely see through the windshield.
It was like,
just let me go.
And here's the funny thing,
like,
I'm not,
I'm not a racist,
I'm not an Islamophobe,
but she was wearing one of the,
uh,
the headscarves,
the fucking Burka things.
And I'm like,
all right,
if we're going to,
if we're going to be very crass as a civilization and very cold and calculating,
how many young white guys driving Toyota Corollas with their fucking mom in the
car,
how many of them have been responsible for terrorist attacks over the last 10,
20,
or a hundred years?
Zero.
You know,
like,
this is ridiculous white guys with their mom and Toyota Corollas.
And I was like,
what is this?
And she's like,
oh,
it's homeland security policy.
I was like,
well,
it's bullshit.
Like I think we have to,
we don't want to go overboard with being too adversarial or to uh,
like unaccepting of the fact that nothing is going to be perfect ever.
We have to acknowledge that.
But I think if we don't put our foot down at some point and see like enough of
this bureaucratic bullshit,
then it's only a matter of time before.
That's the situation in a grocery store parking lot,
you know?
And like people say that's ridiculous.
But that is how mission creep happens is big.
Oh well the TSA needs to keep our grocery store parking lot safe because can,
you could be shot by a psychopath and you don't want that.
And it's like,
where do we draw the line?
Like life is unsafe,
everybody dies guaranteed.
And that's that.
And then like,
we should try to keep airports safe.
We should try to profile people beforehand,
you know,
kind of filter out the threats before they even get there.
All that stuff I'm in favor of,
but we got to have common sense and we're lacking that.
Yeah,
no,
I
agree with you.
I think,
uh,
you're,
you're totally right.
And I think that that's the thing about that people don't recognize about,
it's slowly creeping into new places.
It's like all it would take is one event,
whether it's at a great forum parking lot,
you know,
whether it's sad,
well,
they already,
the TSA wants to start arming their agent,
arming their whatever they are.
They're people because of the shooting at lax.
So now we're going to go from a situation where there's pretty much nobody with
guns at every airport to 20 dumb asses with guns at every airport and you're
just creating an exponentially higher risk of something going wrong.
You know,
somebody is going to make the wrong decision.
Somebody who's going to be jumpy,
you don't need to arm a bunch of people who,
uh,
you know,
are barely able to do their jobs as it is.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
it's definitely a slippery slope.
It's definitely a slippery slope.
And it's like,
what kind of qualifications are these people going to have to decide whether or
not they should pull the trigger?
You heard about what happened to the PA that worked for tosh point?
Oh,
they've got accidentally shot by the cops.
Holy Shit.
No,
I didn't hear responded to someone they knew got stabbed.
He went to help and the cops showed up and he was running out of the place with
the guy who had gotten stabbed.
The guy ran out,
he ran out behind him and the cops unloaded on him.
Wow.
They just start firing on him and you know,
the cops had no idea he was running towards them and they just made a bad
decision.
Now these are cops train police officers that made a,
a slippery decision and they were incorrect.
Right.
And they go to a firing range and they have to pass certain tests.
TSA officers are like rent a cops
basically.
Yeah.
Who knows what kind of stringent safety standards they have to go through.
But um,
I'm not comfortable with all those fucking dudes.
Can.
I've,
I've seen too many of them that it just,
it,
some of them are really cool for sure,
but I've seen too many of them where I'm like,
this guy did not go through a tight filter to get here.
He just didn't,
he's not that bright.
The way they're interacting with people's clunky,
it's rude.
You know?
You see a lot of people that have this authoritative way of talking where they
don't recognize the fact that,
hey man,
you're just a person.
You're a person.
I'm a person.
You,
you don't own me.
You're not better than me.
You know,
you don't get to talk down to me because I forgot to take my belt off.
You know?
Why don't you lighten the fuck up?
I'm not a terrorist.
I'm a human being who is going through your job.
You know?
Just because you have power doesn't mean you should exercise it.
In all fairness,
most of the people I run into a TSA are very pleasant and very nice
too.
Especially when I get in the preapproved line.
It's awesome.
It's almost like,
oh,
this is what it should be.
All the time.
It shouldn't be a special treat.
It should be,
you know that just prescreen the shit out of me.
You're already reading my emails.
Like let's figure this out.
I got on the list where I can be preapproved and can leave my shoes on and
that's fine.
Like I'm okay with that.
Yeah.
That's how it should be.
100% I remember when you used to not have to take a driver's license.
He could give somebody else your ticket.
You could give Brian your ticket and he can go on a fucking plane.
Like don't have to have
a ticket that says David Seaman.
Show your passport.
Do you have any other forms of ID,
sir?
Let me read your DNA.
Can I check your fingerprints?
What's the scar in your hand?
You've ruined your fingerprint.
You know mean.
It's just unbelievably ridiculous that it's still escalating in this.
By the way,
where's the terrorism?
Well,
don't give them,
don't give them any ideas.
I know I'm not saying,
but what I am saying is Boston police arrest man for bringing hoax explosive
device to Boston marathon finish line.
They should eat that guy.
They should cut him up into pieces and serve him to prisoners.
There was a pressure cooker and it too,
like he just made,
oh what a fucking idiot.
Really.
Not a smart God.
What a fucking idiot.
But you know what,
what would have prevented that guy from doing that?
I mean maybe,
maybe if they had more security at the Boston airport or at the Boston marathon.
But really what would have prevented it is if they followed up on all the
creepers like that.
They had been looking at that guy for a long time.
The,
the CIA had been investigating that guy for awhile.
Yeah.
Important piece of shit.
We're a country of 300 million people.
So unless we put everybody under house arrest and like,
you know,
padded bubble wrapped rooms to keep us safe,
some people are going to do crazy shit.
And that's what happens when you have a society where people have rights and
people can have guns and people can drive cars.
Like you're going to have car accidents,
you're gonna have people shooting people.
And if you don't have that,
you'll still have crazy people.
The other day there was a headline story on CNN.
Some school,
I forget where it was,
Wisconsin,
maybe there was a fucking knife thing where this guy went in and a rampage and
knife.
Like a crazy amount of people.
He didn't have a gun.
He was like five people.
Yeah,
it's insane.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and we got a lot of problems in this country.
We definitely have a lot of problems but I think are behavioral problems.
It's what would cause a person to do any of those things.
It's the same thing that what would cause a person have no environmentally
concerned,
no environmental concerns.
If they could profit from it,
what could cause a person to release something on the market that may have
potential horrific side effects without,
you know,
doing the kind of screening that they should do every time.
Something like Vioxx slips through.
Are these pharmaceutical drugs give you strokes?
They find out years later like I know dude,
it's like 30 years old.
He's an MMA fighter and a fucking stroke from taking Vioxx.
I mean that stuff,
they pulled it,
they yanked it.
But there's been a bunch of those things where they just said fuck it,
let it roll.
Let's find out later.
You know maybe weird shit will happen to people,
but we've got to have data run makes him money.
I had a family member have a heart attack from a adverse reaction to a drug
that's relatively new last couple of years it came on the market and it's still
on the market.
Even though this is a known side effect,
like you'll see a,
if you Google it,
you'll see like a law firm's soliciting victims of this,
this issue and I guess whatever bean counter there decided that it would be
massively expensive to to reign in the drug and admit the word fault.
So instead we're just going to say,
you know,
this is the risk of using this medication is,
it's
insane to me that I still see commercials for this drug on TV and like know that
it's responsible for giving a family member or a heart attack.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
And is it just a weird one?
1 million people freak out and blow a gasket on this stuff or is it a real
common side effect?
It's not super common,
but it's also,
from what I,
again,
I'm not a doctor or anything since it just googling around.
It's not super uncommon either.
It's not like,
you know,
you saw the ads from Mesothelioma and nobody actually has it.
This is something where like you get prescribed this instead of the one that's
tried and true and that,
uh,
hospitals have been using for decades with,
you know,
very known a risk profile.
This one replaces that.
And because it's under patent,
they make more money and they claim it's more efficient,
which it may be,
but it also has this small chance of really fucking you over.
What is Mesothelioma?
Cause I see those ads,
they're on all the time on television.
Do you have Mesothelioma?
Yeah,
I honestly don't know.
I think it might be some kind of lung disorder.
And it was from what?
No idea is a,
looks like a cancer that develops from cells.
Oh,
here it is from exposure to asbestos.
Huh?
It's a cancer only from Express's.
Yeah.
Hmm.
So I guess what they're trying to do with those ads is target people that used
to work in offices that have asbestos in them.
So there's,
that has nothing to do with what we're talking about,
but,
no,
but my point is like,
you see those ads online,
like have you,
are you suffering from Mesothelioma contact our law firm?
And I've never met anybody who's suffered from that.
But this is something where if you Google it,
there actually are cases of people having adverse side effects and it's because
it's a new drug.
They're trying to make money and push aside this extremely cheap drug drug that
costs like nothing,
like a dollar and has been used in hospitals for a hundred years and they want
to replace that blood thinner with this new one,
which is not all that tried and true.
And it's just,
you know,
it's gone through the FDA process but then shit happens.
And uh,
I dunno how I got off on this tangent,
but I think,
no.
Yeah.
Well we got off talking about people that are just behavior problems.
It's an uh,
thinking and behavior problem that people are willing to put money over humanity
or the people were willing to commit horrific crimes like I,
what is it that causes someone to be able to run through a school and stab a
bunch of kids?
I mean,
what is it?
Oh,
is he on drugs?
Is it an antidepressant?
Is it a childhood abuse?
Is it trauma?
When he was young and just ruined his mind,
ruined the connections at his mind.
Makes forever.
What are those?
What are those answers?
Because that's not what we ever hear.
All we ever hear is tightened down and security take away the guns but locked
the gates installed guards.
But is that really the answer?
It shouldn't we be trying to figure out at least making an attempt because I
don't hear a fucking peep out of anybody to examine the motivations and the
possibilities.
Like what are the possibilities that could cause someone to become a monster?
What is it,
you know,
what are the variables?
I don't think that when they add more security guards and more checkpoints,
I really don't think it's about making us safer.
And it's not that they don't want us to be safer.
I'm not like super,
uh,
super cynical about this.
But what it is,
is pretty much a jobs program.
It's like this is a way to give people jobs and keep the employment rate right
at decent range.
And if we don't give people these jobs that basically they're just standing
around like what is the abbreviation for Tsa that people use thousand standing
around there.
It's a fucking jobs program.
And so I would much rather see us,
uh,
you know,
why don't those people do something that actually helps the community plant
trees instead of harassing people at an airport or a,
you know,
we don't want to militarize our schools because then every day you're going into
school and subconsciously you're like,
am I a fucking prisoner?
Like why are there guards around here?
It's supposed to be a voluntary thing where like I'm coming for knowledge and to
interact with other people my age and learn something about the world and then
go home and it's not a prison.
So,
yeah,
it is a weird thing that you have to even think about that they even worry about
going to a school and there's guards,
they're like protecting what it's like.
Is it going to get to a point where it's just,
the only thing that's different is that people haven't figured out that they can
attack people at stadiums or figured out that they can attack people at the
mall.
I mean,
once those things start happening on a regular basis,
there really will be some sort of a lock down the parking lot.
We're going to have to show your vin number and they're going to have to read
your DNA.
And
yeah,
it was really a,
when somebody says,
I need your vin number,
it just feels so invasive because they're like,
we own you.
That's like the message that I get.
I realize that they need to do it cause they don't want somebody putting a
explosive device in a car that doesn't have a license plate.
I totally understand the logic.
But just as an individual who,
uh,
goes to airports fairly often,
it's dehumanizing and there's no proof that this makes us safer.
Yeah.
There's no proof that this makes us safer.
And the,
the actual numbers of terrorist attacks,
like not taking anything away from the horrific nature of nine 11 or the Boston
bombings or anything,
the,
the numbers of those things taking place in comparison to the numbers of human
beings is quite staggering.
I mean,
there are very few terrorists attacks and God damn,
there's a lot of people,
there's 300 million fucking people in this country.
Not including transients,
not including vacationers from other countries,
not including illegal aliens.
We really don't know the full number is because when I'm actually,
homes are good at crossing that border.
La is a joke,
like when they try to figure out like the sense of Ella.
Yeah.
You get it.
It's 20 million people in La and approximately a hundred thousand undocumented
workers.
Do you have any,
you don't know how many,
you have no idea how many Mexicans they are.
They aren't,
you're not talking to you about how they're undocumented.
They're hiding.
Yeah.
Go to work,
go to one TACO truck next to a car wash.
It was like a thousand,
uh,
Mexican people there.
But um,
speaking of Mexican immigrants,
this is one of my issues with the media is right now they would have us believe
that the two biggest problems facing all of us,
gay marriage and illegal immigration,
well,
the right about one thing.
It's fucking queers kitchen up on the way,
on the way over here,
the freeway was backed up because there was a wedding right in the middle of the
freeway.
All these gays just getting married,
right and left destroying our way of life.
Yeah,
they're sucking each other off right before they got married.
They don't even believe in the sanctity of marriage in a gay household.
They don't abstain before they get married.
They're not like regular people.
They have sex all the time.
And then we know that the wedding ring goes on your cock.
I'm not sure if they do that where it's how it keeps your Dick hard.
None of 'em abstain ever.
It never abstained.
Did you never going to find a single gay version?
They come out of the gate thing in their own,
but
they really had a wedding in the middle of a fuck head.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
so you have an eight year old on the podcast.
We have to explain things to him.
That should be obvious.
I thought you really said there was and I'm like,
wait,
that's ridiculous.
That's a good idea though.
Everyone I know about your wedding.
I'm so deadpan about everything that people can't even tell when I'm joking
about shit,
but the other,
it'd be 99.9% of the people listening.
Brian's half awake,
he woke up 15 minutes.
He hasn't had his bulletproof coffee.
It worked out.
So that's what it is.
You're tired.
The illegal immigration thing,
it's like if we want to solve this,
like instead of putting all these judge Dredd border patrol people along the
border,
which I don't think it's a terrible idea because we do need some border
protection,
but it's enormously expensive.
It's dehumanizing.
We're rounding these people up like animals.
Why don't we start by making it so that American corporations stop fucking
promoting them coming over here.
If we are not giving them any kind of jobs,
the immigration with,
to a large extent,
stop it.
They're coming over here cause it sucks in Mexico and they can get jobs here and
send money.
Yeah.
But I don't think the,
the rational response is stop giving them jobs once they get here because it's
never going to happen.
There's always going to be landscapers and there's always going to be
construction.
Agriculture.
Like any vegetables you bought in the supermarket have probably been picked by a
legal day.
Laborers sure.
Go to AWC star and get a strawberry.
Who are you getting from?
You're getting that shit from someone who probably came to America to find a
better life for their family.
So I don't think you can say the corporations are at fault.
The human being should be allowed to go to a better place.
You should be allowed to take your fucking family to a better place.
And everybody over here that's got a good is scared that these poor people are
going to come over here and fuck everything up.
And that's what the,
the real fear is.
What about passports?
What an antiquated idea that is because I think as long as you're not on the
Interpol list and you're not wanted for something,
you should just be able to go wherever you want.
As long as it's an allied country,
you shouldn't need a passport.
That's valid because it's like they know how to you find out if someone's on the
Interpol list without a passport.
Yeah.
I mean I guess you need some kind of system,
but I think it can be done with what they have already.
Like they know what you're doing at every second of the day.
This is what's so Orwellian and fucked up.
It's like yesterday was tax day and we saw all this stuff
like make sure you file your taxes on time.
And it's like,
what is this?
Like?
What kind of mind benders?
We know that the NSA is sharing data with agencies like the IRS giving them,
you know,
we know that they're sharing financial data with those kinds of agencies and IRS
knows exactly how much you owe because they get the 10 90 nines every year from
the people who pay you more than $600 so they know everything.
Why don't they just send you a fucking bill and then if there's a problem you
can dispute it the same as a credit card bill instead of like,
I've got a guest to make sure that I'm paying the right amount and if I don't
match their number,
they are,
we have right here.
Even Donald Rumsfeld who I consider to be the closest thing to like the man
that's out there tweeted out the other day about how the IRS is just out of
control.
Like it makes no sense anymore.
It's not a logical thing.
Like there's some Democrat Foreign Office.
It's true,
it's partisan,
it's just attacking the other side.
But I think in general like why don't you just send me a bill,
just send me a bill.
And like in most cases I think most people are like,
oh this is what I,
oh cool.
20% 25% what are the fuck it is?
People can pay it cause that's how it works for cable.
It's what?
How it works for your credit card,
for your car payment.
Why isn't your tax bill the same one?
Because they don't want people to pay or get money back.
Most people get money back.
That I know of.
You know,
unless you're making over a certain amount of money,
you actually get money back.
Everyone's like,
oh,
it's time.
I get my tax check yet.
Well here's,
here's a fucker.
Here's a fucker.
State taxes.
You don't always have to pay him.
That's the fucker.
Like if we lived in Washington state or if we have done,
we lived in Vegas or la,
I think Texas as well.
Florida,
Florida.
Few places don't have to pay the state taxes.
That's 10% so if you live,
if say if you make a nice living,
you know you make a,
let's go to a hundred grand a year because it's easy.
You make $100,000 a year,
you're given $10,000 to state of California.
So you're paying $10,000 just to live here.
So you imagine if you rent was 1000 bucks and then on top of that you pay
another thousand bucks to the state.
That is what your doing.
If you live in California or if you live in a place that has state taxes,
like how does Washington state survive?
How come they don't have to steal my money?
Like what?
What's going on here?
That Vegas doesn't need that 10% what's going on here that Texas has figured out
how to fucking stay afloat without stealing money from the people that live
there?
Like what does that state tax,
why wouldn't everybody gets a piece of what?
So you can hire more people to do a shitty job of running things and you and
just keep putting jobs on the books to eat up tax revenue.
We got it.
100,000 jobs,
you should be fired.
The government should be fired for creating any jobs.
If you creating more jobs and you already have,
that means there's more government,
more government should mean you're fired.
You're fucking up.
We don't need more government.
Need less people telling you what to do and less shit that's illegal.
That would smooth things out for so many people and let drugs be legal.
Boom.
I balance your economy.
It's done so over.
I still,
I
think Obama,
uh,
the other day I was,
I was in Venice beach getting lunch and I got a beer and a burger and enjoyed
something that's known to the state of California to have medicinal benefit.
And I looked up in the,
uh,
whenever this place was,
this restaurant and right over the door was the picture of Obama from his Hawaii
days.
He had the hat on and he was smoking a Doobie and for like a half a second,
I thought,
that's my guy right there.
That's 2008 campaign trail Obama.
And then of course,
that's not what we got.
We got smart Bush.
Instead,
we got somebody who can like come onto the tonight show or the view or something
and just have the host eating out of his hand by the end of the interview.
So he's much smarter and more eloquent,
but it's still doing a lot of the crazy shit that Bush was doing.
And I think that he could still,
uh,
kind of like,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Like,
uh,
come out ahead and like still come across as a good president.
If you were to just legalize weed at the federal level,
I think most people be like,
oh,
okay.
He actually did something meaningful that will be around 50 years from now.
And it's not just like,
I'm going to tax,
I'm going to find the shit out of you if you don't sign up for my healthcare
website.
And,
uh,
I've done more drone strikes than any other president in history.
I've allowed NSA programs to expand and set almost nothing in response if you
are,
even with all that shit,
which I think is awful.
Legalize weed at the federal level and I would rate him as a good president.
You're hilarious.
First of all,
I don't think that that's a joint.
I think that picture is a cigarette.
I've looked at it many times.
I've studied it like this approved or film.
Let's look at it quite closely.
Have you ever noticed this when you're high,
like everything seems to be a reminder that your high no,
because I've been getting high longer than you son.
I never hold a cigarette like that.
He's really enjoying it.
It made them slow closing on that bitch.
Let's get a CSI on this one.
Look how closer.
Look how it's not like,
like it's looks squished and stuff and was a roll joints.
Get the smoke signature and know what?
Here's a,
here's another,
here's another uh,
point.
Um,
look how far down he's already smoking it.
He would basically be in the filter.
If it was a cigarette.
You're right.
100%.
Unless he wrote his own cigarette.
He's a cowboy.
I know dudes who do that rolled menthols.
Oh wait,
a black joke.
You fuck.
How dare you?
He's the commander in chief.
You're a man.
Boy.
He was the commander in chief.
You son of a bitch.
What is wrong?
Does he smoke?
Menthols cause he used to smoke.
Right.
I think Michelle made him quit cigarettes.
When you're the goddamn president you can't smoke anymore cause it's the
stupidest thing people do you think he does?
Fuck yeah,
he was smoking in office.
His,
at least his first term and that job is so stressful.
There's no way you're quitting smoking while you're a precedent.
Yeah,
you could quit.
You can quit if you really want it to seem funny to think about him having a
window open in the Oval Office just puffing.
Let me think of just the amount of stress that he's going through anyway.
Your cigarettes are not going to relieve that.
We kind of stress you must be going through be the goddamn president mean your
hair goes white.
Yeah,
well that's why I try not to be super anti Obama because once he's gone in two
years it's going to be somebody else and like 98% of the shit we're complaining
about right now,
it will still exist.
I quit smoking because of Michelle Sweetie,
six years.
They do seem like a nice Kabul,
like they're really do seem like they're like each other.
I mean,
I don't know.
People were good at bullshitting,
but well it conservatives attack her for uh,
promoting eating like healthy eating habits.
And I'm like,
of all the things of all the things for a first lady to be doing,
I think this is the best use of big government.
Like let's encourage people to eat healthy.
It's much better than spying on everybody.
I don't think we should.
Yeah.
She grew a garden at the White House growing vegetables and shit.
Sustainability and making your own food.
That's good stuff.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody can be a good president.
I think the machine behind government is too fucking big.
It's like what we were talking about about corporations and you know,
the,
the constant need for,
we were actually talking about it before the podcast about the,
the infinite growth paradigm.
The Peter Joseph always talks about these corporations need to constantly keep
growing and that's really not possible.
It's really not possible.
And that they,
when,
when a corporation starts acting like that sort of money generating machine,
and that's the bottom line is it always has to continue to generate money no
matter what they come up with.
All sorts of compromises,
compromise of ethics,
compromises of morals,
just so that they can figure out a way to continue to raise that bottom line,
keep that money coming in.
And I think essentially the government at one,
at a certain point becomes that,
I mean it's what Eisenhower warned about when he was leaving office,
the military industrial complex taking over.
And even if it's not the direct reason why something happens,
even if it wasn't a financial reason why something,
uh,
why,
why there is an a military action,
why we go to war once we're there and the money is pouring in to these
contractors,
the money is pouring into weapons manufacturers,
the money is pouring in the cutting that money off and to having a
justification,
you're going to get resistance and they get resistance from incredibly powerful
people with incredibly influential ties that have a lot of fucking money.
And that is a fact.
And that's unavoidable.
And that's just mathematics,
human nature one oh one.
It's real simple.
We're greedy bitches.
And that's why I'm excited about digital money because I,
I honestly agree with you that this structure like is not going to change.
It's because of what you just said,
that these powerful people want their budgets to remain at least where they are
and probably much larger in the future because they have people on their payroll
and they want to keep those TSA jobs.
They want to keep those NSA analyst job and want to buy a weekend home.
So it's all,
I think it's like 80% about money and uh,
all this shit is funded because the government is printing it's own money and
then that's what we use as currency.
And I really don't think that so that if the issue is structural and not
personality,
in other words,
like Obama's not responsible for all the problems in this country because a lot
of this shit started in a bush.
A lot of it started under Clinton.
A lot of it started under Reagan.
A lot of it started 30 years ago.
So,
uh,
if it's not personality driven,
the problem and it's just structured,
driven,
the only way you'll see change is to change the structure itself.
And as new people come into government that that same structure is going to keep
it staying the same form.
It's going to destroy them as well because,
uh,
who did I,
they get sucked into it.
Like the wolf of Wall Street guy.
Yeah.
We'll just become a part of it.
Even if you become a congressman,
like you're not getting on the important committees,
you're just sitting in the back and you have one vote out of like 450 fucking
people.
So you get on TV and you get to have a moral voice.
But in terms of changing the direction the government goes,
you don't have much say and how many people in Congress are actually like legit
young people that we can relate to?
I can name two and then there's Ron Wyden who's older but still to me seems like
he's an honest guy.
So I can think of three people between the Congress and Senate who I would trust
to actually represent,
uh,
like everyday people's interests.
Do you think that it's even necessary to have a government that established and
set up the way we have it today with representatives when there's the,
the access to communication is so instantaneous.
It's like the whole idea of having a senator or having a congress from having a
representative is like,
there was no way for the people to just go and individually talk and give their
opinions on things.
There was no way.
There's too many fucking people.
Well,
and they're too far apart from each other.
It would take,
you know,
when the country was established,
you got to literally ride an animal across the country.
Yeah.
I mean that's the dumbest fucking idea.
Could you imagine if today everyone outlawed cars?
We ought to ride horses.
How,
how would,
and there was no more internet.
How the fuck would you ever pass a law?
How the,
how would you ever,
you know,
state laws,
how would you ever deal with the federal government's influence on it would be
so baffling.
But I think the founding fathers,
uh,
we always assumed that I representative democracy was put in a place because of
the technical limitations that is just like you just said,
it's impossible to get everybody to d DC to tally up where their votes would
lie.
So instead we use representatives and we send them,
right.
And we assume that that's the only reason why they chose this structure.
And I don't think it is,
I think part of it is that they were terrified of dumb people.
They were actually worried about mob rule because they'd seen that happen in
other governments.
And you see it happened today,
like Reddit,
95% of the time is on top of it's shit and is a great source of information.
What about the 5% of the time where they,
they find the wrong fucking suspect for the Boston bombing and that shit goes to
the front page and some guy's life is ruined for the next six months or possibly
forever.
You know,
he's never going to able to get a job because you Google that name.
First thing you see is Boston bombing suspect.
Even if he's cleared,
you don't want to hire that person.
And that's a case where like the crowd mind fucks up and if we give everybody
instant access to that to real say in government,
first of all I think it's a good idea cause I think overall,
uh,
like the good wins out over the bullshit.
But I'm just trying to give an example of I think why they chose that.
A representative system.
I think you're probably right.
I think that's definitely a valid point is that there are dumb people and they
can gather together and it gets fucking terrifying when you're just dealing with
the one person,
one vote.
Sort of a paradigm.
Yeah.
Um,
did you see what's going on in reddit where people are being outed as a being
paid posters and paid shills to post in these conspiracy theories sites?
I didn't see that.
What I saw recently is that the technology subreddit,
which is one of the most popular,
is using a bot to automatically filter out posts.
And somebody did research and posted the keywords that this Bot is filtering and
it's like serious thought control.
Like you're not allowed to publish a headline that has the word Tesla in it.
You know,
like the electric car company not allowed to have the word bitcoin not allowed
to have the word.
Uh,
NSA,
Keith Alexander,
you got to look this thing up like it's,
wait a minute,
that's crazy.
This is read it.
This is the technology subright it's this big controversy now because people are
like,
well this is fucking retarded.
How could they stop that?
Are they trying to prevent advertising?
Like what are they trying to do?
I think the original intent was to not have the whole page filled with like
basically the same story.
I think if there's a big NSA revelation,
you have 10 articles and it's all the same content,
but just like different people saying the same thing.
I think that was the original template.
It's also like why don't you let read it?
Do read it.
Like the whole point is a good content gets upvoted.
If people aren't interested,
they'll get rid of it on their own.
So you don't have,
it really strikes me.
Is that Brian,
what do you got there?
Just showing why shown desk quads read it.
I want to know who,
see what he's talking about it and knowing what the technology subreddit type in
type in reddit and daily dot.
And the article should come up.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's,
um,
but it's troubling because I use very try use that as a major source of news and
I'm sure a lot of people do now.
The is,
is Tesla such a popular subject that they had to do that.
I mean,
how many different articles are written about Tesla is that they had to use that
word.
Well,
the other issue is like if that's the people are interested in this week,
why don't you let that rise to the top?
Like who the fuck are you to create this false structure?
Like you're not allowed to talk about the NSA.
Well that affects every facet of people's technology right now.
And you know,
like it's,
it's huge.
That's insane mood.
If some new news comes out,
it has to do with the Teslin NSA and you can't,
you literally can't make the post.
I want people to see this article.
So they just know that I'm not like making it up,
but to call,
they give me the title of what it is.
Uh,
it was an article in the daily dot.
And it was like reddit technology subreddit something.
Okay.
I'm just googling daily.
Dot.
Red.
It's mods or censoring dozens of words from our technology.
That's,
that's the,
uh,
say what you want about Reddit's technology.
Uh,
one of the popular forums,
blah,
blah.
One of its most popular forums.
Just don't say Nsa net neutrality,
Comcast,
bitcoin,
or any of the roughly 50 other words that will secretly get your post deleted.
Holy Shit.
Isn't that crazy?
There's a bot in our slash technology ready to delete any so called
controversial headline.
You try to submit.
That's unbelievable.
A headline about net neutrality gets deleted.
That's insane.
And July read it.
Dropped too.
Controversial subreddits are atheism and our politics from being automatic
automatic subscriptions for new users to see that.
So it kind of Orwellian too.
It's like,
why is politics controversial?
That's a big part of why people visit sites like Reddit is to see what's
happening in the political world.
And,
uh,
you just had Alexis on,
right?
Yes.
Maybe you could email him and try to get him to fix technology.
Maybe I could.
I will try,
but I don't think he's involved in the day to day anymore.
What I understand this is not like Reddit's staff doing this since these mods
who are volunteers.
And once you become a mod,
it's very hard to get rid of you.
And there's like no accountability.
Like,
we don't know who these fucking people are.
All we know is the actions they take.
Right?
We don't like,
honestly,
like how do we know that a technology mod is not some shill for the fossil fuel
industry who just doesn't want to see Tesla rise to the top?
We don't know that.
Yeah.
I'm uh,
emailing him right now to ask him what the hell this is.
It's,
um,
it doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense why they would do that.
Like,
why would you have knit net neutrality?
What are you doing,
dude?
It's going to have to type all the keywords into it post and try to make a
thread and see what happens.
Um,
can you like,
can you buy a new Tesla with bitcoin?
Yeah.
With the coins tower seven
tower stuff.
That's how you make sure that your conversation is always logged by the NSA.
Just close it with tower seven.
Yeah,
that's the big one,
right?
People love that one tower staff.
It's a juicy one.
Any conspiracy theorists that doesn't have an opinion about tower seven,
it's not worth his salt.
You got to have an opinion.
But Eddie Bravo.
We'll fucking hold you down until you tell him that that tower seven was a
demolition and we'll fucking hold you down.
He doesn't,
you can't say,
I don't know.
You would if you had to guess.
But if your life depended on it,
does it?
I don't know.
Yeah.
All right.
I made the threat.
Did it work?
It seems like it worked.
It went up.
We'll see.
How long till the Reddit Swat team,
uh,
deletes here,
but it's not,
it can't have is a Bot.
It won't do it.
What does it say?
Try to submit it again.
It said you're already submitted it.
I don't think it's already been submitted.
What did you double summit?
No,
I just put it in cause they ask,
you know,
you have to put a link down so I didn't know what to link it to.
I'll put it link to your website and see what,
don't do that again.
Trouble look into your own websites.
Do or are you looking at Lincoln,
your shit to my shit or you'll get the podcast from reddit
and not doing it anymore.
I don't think I would email and Alexis or onion and get to the bar.
He was cool.
Yeah.
Interesting story.
Cool Dude.
It's funny because he's um,
I think it's important to have guys like that who are willing to speak out for
things that are really important instead of just taking the money and being
like,
I'm just going to go fuck hot models and live on,
you know,
like he definitely doesn't have to be the one telling us about SISPA and soap
and all this stuff and fight for the future.
I think that's his organization.
He's a young idealist who's really smart and he figured out a way to make a
shitload of money,
came up with a cool thing and you know,
he's kind of continuing along that same trajectory.
And people,
people like me definitely noticed that.
Like if he,
I'm sure in 10 years he's going to be doing even bigger stuff.
And I think will respect the fact that he spoke out when a lot of cowards that
companies like,
well,
I don't need to alienate myself with companies like big tech companies.
They're are not saying shit and we know this is wrong,
so why don't you say something?
Not only that,
and we find out that they cooperated with the NSA and gave him back doors to
technology and software and it's,
it's very,
very frustrating because you want to think about,
I think that one of the unique aspects of technology is the morality that sort
of inherently goes with superintelligent people.
That there's so much goddamn money in technology that people,
well,
Whoa,
let's not be as greedy.
We don't have to be as greedy.
We make so much goddamn money.
But think about how much money Google makes.
What's their motto?
Don't be evil.
I mean that's,
that's like a really good model for a giant multibillion dollar corporation and
that's not something that existed anywhere else.
Like it didn't exist with clothing.
It didn't exist with giant corporations that were involved in natural resources.
You never hear that.
You never hear that kind of a model motto attached to a gas company.
Meanwhile,
gas companies make more money than anybody.
This new technology and the new,
the new money that's coming out of technology is generated by intensely creative
and intelligent people and I think what we're seeing from those people as
opposed to just money grubbers people that tried to like something that's not as
complex as technology sort of doesn't have the same thought process behind it.
There's not,
there's not as much introspective thinking,
there's not as much ethical calculations.
It's a different way of looking at the world that I think is being presented by
tech companies that in my opinion is it's very promising because I think it
gives you a lot of hope for the future.
When you see like this is a trend is a very obvious trend in my opinion,
that these,
these guys are more ethical and more moral and more conscious.
It's more globally conscious.
It's a more optimistic view of the world.
And I think if you're a recent person entering the workforce for the first time
and you're looking at jobs online,
really hold out and don't go for the shitty defense contractor that you know is
doing evil stuff.
Go instead for the company that is creating cool apps or you know,
creating new efficiencies and payments or whatever it is that you're interested
in.
Do that instead because technology,
um,
can go on so many different directions.
You don't want to be the person creating the marketing for the next like fucking
range of drones.
You want to be the person working at Google or uh,
or even Microsoft and just creating better search because even things like that
create more of a positive impact on humanity than I think almost anything else.
And I think that the rest of the world is slowly but surely forcing America to
catch the fuck up on a lot of our archaic shit like Canada,
Canada just released all limitations on prostitution.
They just said,
stop.
Who Cares?
Is that like the Rob Ford Act of 2014 you know,
that's crap.
The cracks now,
legal American smoke at an office and still stay there.
He's a phenomenal being.
I was watching some of his fat guy that does blow.
What's phenomenal about that?
And he became mayor of Toronto.
I,
it's crazy.
Yeah,
it's amazing that he's still mayor.
That's don't,
don't you have to do debates or something like they don't realize that he's
crazy right away.
Well,
how the fuck that Bush get in office?
You know what I mean?
People like people that are like them.
There's a lot of fat coke heads out there in Toronto,
I guess.
So they're there,
but there's not,
you know,
Toronto's an amazing spot.
It's really powerful.
A financial,
I don't that up to get us pulled down from youtube.
Every time we put a youtube clip up these days,
we're getting fucking pulled down.
But the other thing that's cool about the,
uh,
the tech world is that they're very,
um,
they hold nothing sacred.
So in the 90s,
they're like,
we're gonna reinvent communication.
And they did that with email and instant messenger and then all the more
advanced shit that came after like social media and now they've turned their
eyes to money and they're like,
we're going to reinvent money,
were no longer happy with a massaging the balls of these credit card companies
and getting a small fee in return.
We want to own the whole process from start to finish.
And we want it to be faster.
We don't want to get clearance from credit card companies before we change our
marketing or our design and we just wouldn't have total freedom.
You know,
it's the same with like,
um,
with what Google does,
they don't really ask for permission before indexing your site.
They just do it right.
And I think that's a really positive force in the world.
Like a who is,
it says like do it and then ask permission later.
Like obviously that um,
it's some like business guru,
I forget who it was,
but it's either like Branson or somebody like that.
I just read it recently.
Uh,
but I think that's a great mindset and it's so much better than the government
mindset of are you following all the regulations?
Like it was never supposed to be the American way that the first thing you think
about is what is the government going to think.
It's better to ask for forgiveness or beg for forgiveness than to ask for
permission.
That's it.
Um,
I think that that's all well and good except for environmental concerns.
Oh,
I,
I totally,
the real issue is,
you know,
when people do things and they don't ask and then you deal with the cleanup.
We,
we agree
as a society to play this game where the individual can be enriched if you're
smart.
And that game is capitalism and we continue to play it because it's more
efficient than anything else.
But I think you do need to have referees who say,
okay,
so we're playing this game where you can make a lot of money if you do something
that's more efficient than anybody else.
So you do it cooler,
you do it faster.
But if you're fucking up a shared resource,
then that's what the government steps in and tells you,
you can't do this and you have to pay this and you have to fix this because,
uh,
the,
the environment is not owned by corporations.
It's actually owned by citizens of the United States and it's owned by citizens
of,
of a whatever country you happen to be in,
like your land is your land.
And we all have the shared air.
We all have shared oceans.
Like what happens in Japan with their fucked up nuclear reactors affects the
Sushi here in Los Angeles,
at least in theory.
So we have to have a more global mindset.
I know net right now just by saying global mindset,
they're at least 10 people saying that I'm like a Bilderberg,
a one world order shill or something,
but really like it's fucking stupid to not go more global when everything
already is.
It's like right now we're already global society,
but we allow corporations to take advantage of the loopholes and pretend like
we're not global.
Why don't we get rid of that?
Well,
uh,
I think that if the Internet continues its path right now,
the path that we're on right now of the distribution of information,
of connecting everybody together,
it's going to see more and more ridiculous that there's nations.
It's going to see more and more ridiculous that there's places that are lines in
the dirt that you can't cross through.
I mean,
it's just weird.
It's weird.
It's a weird concept.
If there was fences over each state,
that would be intolerable.
Right.
But that's not much different than fences over countries.
We just decide that it's different and I think that as we connect with each
other more and more in the idea of nations become more and more ridiculous,
then the ideas of,
oh like this place owns the resources.
Like if Ohio,
we had all pay Ohio because that's where all the water came from.
But like what?
Like [inaudible] just cause you're in the right patch of dirt,
you don't want the water from Ohio.
He probably gets Badwater herpes water.
Sure.
Yeah.
You've done tests.
Um,
but you know,
I think that what we're,
we're saying makes sense.
Ultimately like from an objective standpoint,
it's just that the system that's in place is not an objective system.
It's not a rational system.
It's a system that runs on momentum.
Well that that's again why the digital money thing I think is the first step and
actually changing this system because the structure will stay the same.
If we continue to do all the same stuff 100 years from now,
we'll still have countries and passports and drones and all the rest of this
shit.
The only way is to like rethink really fundamental parts of what we're doing.
And if we do that it,
it just changes where the money comes from and it reallocates it to better
things.
I think that individuals are better deciders of how to spend money then a
government agency.
No,
I think you're right.
Um,
I think the government agencies,
the problem with them is that it's just a bunch of people,
right?
You know,
the prop calling something to government then giving it power.
You just giving power to people over people and there are certain point time
people need kind of figure out what they want to give other people power over.
You know,
do you want to give people power over your sex life?
Do you want to give people power over your diet?
When New York comes along and says,
you can't have big gulps anymore,
and everybody just goes,
okay,
well hey,
fuck you.
No,
you can't tell me what kind of soda I can drink dummy.
If I want to drink a 35 ounce soda or whatever the hell it is.
Why do you care?
I buy a 30 ounce soda.
How about I go to the store and I get a one leader?
I get a big giant one liter bottle and I drank it.
Fuck you.
You can't tell me what to eat or what to drink.
What,
what kind of nonsense is that?
Have you covered all the bases?
If you solved all the burglaries,
have you solved all the rape cases?
If it didn't,
then shut the fuck up and leave the soda alone.
Well,
that's my issue with the whole healthcare.gov thing too,
is like,
okay,
so if it's so good,
people should want to sign up for it and you should incentivize them.
You should advertise it as you're doing,
but you shouldn't make it a requirement in the,
it shouldn't be like,
we're going to find the shit out of you if you don't sign up.
And by the way,
every year the fine gets bigger.
That's like some kind of harassment,
psychological shit,
right?
Like 1% this year,
2% next year.
Like are you a child?
You know,
like what is that?
It should be totally voluntary.
And,
uh,
I got my,
um,
I got my foot infected recently.
I had a blister and got infected.
And uh,
I went to one of those walking clinics and it was $79 for the visit and I didn't
see a doctor.
It was like an RN or something.
Cause for just the gross for some dudes,
gross foot blister,
you don't need a neurosurgeon,
you don't have to pay a lot of money.
She looked at it and about 30 seconds she goes,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to prescribe you Catholics.
She prescribes it.
I'm taking it every six hours.
My infection has gone now and just have to take for the next few days as a
preventative thing.
And uh,
that prescription with no insurance was $20.
So my whole visit was $100.
I didn't cost taxpayers anything.
I didn't cost,
uh,
myself,
anything beyond that hundred dollar visit.
Why can't we do that?
Why can't it just be a product you buy?
Like anything else?
Well,
don't you think that what happens is exactly what we're talking about before
you're dealing with a corporation is trying to make a shitload of money.
They pay a lot of money to get a politician into office.
The lobby,
the special interest groups,
finance campaigns,
they get them in,
okay,
he's our guy now.
He wants to do Obamacare.
Okay,
let's attach this fucking compassionate care act or whatever the hell you want
to call it.
Name it name.
We're gonna.
We're gonna make more money this way.
This way we're going to force people to buy way.
Hey,
we're going to have more of a subscription in my more of this
dumb people out there.
Wonder why the insurance companies were so supportive of what was supposed to be
a huge reform of their industry.
It's because in exchange,
Obama is like,
you're going to have a captive audience of every single citizen is now required
to buy your product.
It's like,
what do you think would happen to the price of iPhones if you were required by
law to have one on you at all times?
The opposite is socialized medicine.
It's is it's like a disgusting,
like sort of a twist on that system.
Like the idea that the government or that the people's taxes,
like all the money that we pay in California,
this 10% tax thing,
state tax,
if that went to pre health care,
I would be super supportive of it if we found out that the reason why California
pay state taxes is that everybody who lives in state tax in California rather
has free health care.
I'd be like,
that's fantastic.
I'd be happy to give up a sizeable chunk of my income if I knew that people were
being taken
are on every,
everybody,
everybody graduates from high school and they're not a retard.
When they graduate,
they know something about the political world.
They know something about,
uh,
they take a psychology class.
They don't become some psycho shooter.
They understand things about their own psychology.
I would be in favor of that.
I'd be in favor of school system.
It's not completely broken.
Well,
it's also
cool system that's manageable as far as the numbers.
When you're a teacher and you've got 40 kids in your class,
there's no way you can give them individual attention.
There's no way.
Our class
rethink keeping 40,
uh,
hormonally charged kids in a room for eight hours a day sitting in chairs.
We've got to rethink that whole paradigm cause you could do is everybody has an
Ipad,
you read that day's assignment and once a week you all meet up at a fucking
Starbucks.
And if you have any questions than the person who's like your ra or ta or
whatever,
it's like,
okay,
yeah,
here's how you solve this one.
And then a lot of it could be collaborative online and not have a school where
they show up at school,
basically just not have a school.
And then you,
you,
you limit the risk of some psycho coming to the school and blowing people away.
You limit the cost and you could still have like a school,
you can still have like a gym and a shared area for people to hang out and
discuss stuff.
But why do you need to trap people in a building eight hours a day?
Well,
I
point in some ways,
but in other ways that's like a really valuable time for learning human
interaction.
No.
Yeah.
I mean I think people are already like,
uh,
Asperger's as burglary enough without,
yeah,
with x boxes and internet connections.
You'd never have to go outside and interact with people.
Amazon prime,
you just shit delivered.
We kind of want to keep people as connected as possible.
Now that that's a valid point and a,
I'm just kind of,
when they're young,
we're thinking out loud,
but there's,
there's some validation to it too.
I mean,
I think the idea isn't that it would necessarily keep people from interacting
with each other.
What it would do is keep people from being forced to be slaves to a system stuck
in a box learning 50 in a class,
one unmotivated teacher.
Totally ineffective way of going about it.
But the,
the,
the big thing about school is that social interaction.
It's where you learn how to talk to girls.
It's where you weren't learning clicks.
It's where you learn,
you know,
how to deal with negative and positive influences.
There's a lot to be learned in school other than just the stuff that they cheat
you just interacting with each other.
Uh,
forms the basis,
like the framework of how we interact when we get into the workplace.
Yeah.
And you need,
your brain needs that development.
Well,
I think that,
you know,
otherwise you're dealing with wild people.
Just wild
people that have never,
and then you're going to have to try to hire those people and get them to be in
your cubicle all day.
It's like a cat that hasn't been domesticated.
Exactly.
You ever have a feral cat?
I've never had one,
but I've interacted with them before and they just do whatever they want.
Yeah.
I had a feral cat I couldn't eat.
I was the only one who could pick him up if anybody else tried to pick them up.
Even if I picked on beat.
Yes.
And then I pick him up.
But he would relax once I,
once I started petting me per like crazy,
like you're not trying to kill him,
but he was a constant freak out.
Yeah.
You're going to get a little bit of that mingling and there's that.
It also not gonna be able to pick out the psychosis is easy if you're not
constantly like looking at like Billy's bringing skin cats to school.
Like I'm maybe we should sit down with his fucking parents and find out what's
going on with Billy.
Yeah,
see it common well here,
there was this story recently of some guy who shot up a synagogue I think and
the most recent guy and I said,
yeah,
I read the,
I read the article and it was like he had been saying for awhile like I want to
kill Jews and if somebody is literally thinking the same things as Hitler,
like maybe,
maybe somebody should take note of that and bring that guy in for a
psychological evaluation.
You have a little sit down with homeboy and find out how serious he is about
this project.
Yeah.
And since the NSA has already logging in large stuff,
maybe you check his credit card records that he just bide gone last week.
You know like then you have correlation and that's where I think this stuff
could actually be useful instead of just expensive bullshit.
Let's see here.
He's maxed out.
He bought 300 copies of mine count.
Yeah.
Might want to pay him a visit.
Might want to sit down and talk about why it needs all that ammo.
Hello.
Oh there's no way they can keep track.
That's the thing about people monitoring people's cell phones and shit and all
that stuff.
The idea that they're all there.
There's someone assigned to David Seaman listening to every call.
It's hilarious.
Yeah,
it's truly hilarious cause the amount of data you're talking about,
it's fucking staggering for one person.
Even how fast we browse the Internet now.
Like I'll be on a website for about eight seconds,
like click like seven other tabs.
You know,
it's,
it's a lot of data.
It's too much.
If you look at your own history and you're trying to look at your own history
cause you're trying to look for a website that you saw that you forgot to book
mark,
you go through your own history like Ah,
so much the amount of shit that we're exposed to today as opposed to our
grandparents is just unbelievable.
It's unbelievable for the mind.
I would love to see if they could go back in time and take a a guy from the 19
hundreds like 1919 take him and put electrodes on his brain and find out like
what kind of,
what gets stimulated during a regular day,
regular eight hour day.
And then take a guy from 2014 in Manhattan,
same,
you know,
same program running on his brain and find out what's going on in his brain.
I bet one of them looks like a firefly buzzing around a campfire and the other
one looks like a fireworks display,
like the grand finale at Disneyland.
Just don't judge,
don't judge on the amount of information,
just slamming into your fucking synapses.
It's just we're not designed for this man were not designed.
So I think part of what we're doing when we're trying to manage civilization is
we're,
we're trying to catch up to all this shit that's happened that's been erupting
all around us.
We were like,
give that and then then there's this and then fuck and ha ha ha.
Well the,
that's how the government's been responding to bitcoin recently.
It's like a,
if you look at an Internet meme of a dumb dog,
like some dumb oblivious dog governments and like some of these big vested banks
that have been around forever are on the railroad tracks.
This dumb ass dog looking at a train coming in their direction and they're like,
is this something that's going to affect me?
It's like,
and it's not just any train.
It's fucking bullet train moving at 350 miles an hour.
And whenever that train hits the dog,
it's not even going to feel it.
It's going to be just an explosion of disgusting flesh and for,
but that's what they're at right now is a combination of curiosity,
a bit of animosity and like,
how is this going to affect us?
It's,
it's like it'd be like record companies looking at Napster and going,
this is interesting.
Is this going to affect our bottom line at all?
What's also the,
the just the sheer amount of different things that you would have to pay
attention to,
to truly manage.
Yeah.
I like the idea of being a president in 1919 was a really rational idea that you
could have a guy who had managed our budget and the military and this guy
assigned to defense,
and this is,
you know,
but in 2014 good God damn luck.
There's too many things.
There's no way any one person has their finger on the pulse of all these things.
It's like someone says to you,
hey man,
what do you think about what's going on at the Bundy ranch?
Like,
I don't fucking know,
like what's going on at the Bundy ranch?
I can't know.
It doesn't,
ah,
you fucking Shill,
you know,
like you can't know everything there.
Every day there's a hundred new stories that have huge implications to our
society,
to our world,
to the way we progress.
Like where are we going in the future?
Is it going to be affected by these events,
by these decisions,
by these technologies?
Every day there's a hundred of them.
And every day everyone has to try to pay attention to as many of them as you
can.
And there's a new hundred tomorrow.
Good luck.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it's exponential.
So a year from now,
10 years from now,
it's going to be unrecognizable.
There's going to be so much information coming at you on a daily basis and the
changes will be so rapid.
It's almost unpredictable when you,
when we try to look at the idea of exponential growth.
Like I talked to Ray Kurzweil about that and he was talking to me about the
criticisms that he's,
um,
he's been given about this idea of the singularity,
about,
um,
technological singularity that there's going to be some sort of a technology
that's so groundbreaking that it changes humanity in reality as we know it and
it's probably right around the corner.
I agree with that actually.
I agree with it too and I'm too stupid to understand all of it.
But when he describes it,
when he describes exponential,
then you really wrap your head around it like that.
It doesn't matter that it took a hundred years to make,
you know,
this machine after that machine was made.
What matters is once a technology is born,
then technology's branch off of that at an incredibly rapid rate.
And as new technologies come in,
it makes it easier for new innovation to be established as well.
And then it just swarms and it gets this incredible frenzy where it's
unpredictable as far as like how fast it's going to go.
And he thinks it's like 20,
49.
That's what his opinion is.
His opinion and his studying all of these different graphs and looking at the
exponential growth of technology is trying to figure out like when it's all
going to come to a head.
But even he's his guessing.
No one really knows.
There might be some new thing that comes out next month at of Finland that no
one saw coming.
That changes a whole fucking ball of wax.
And it's,
it's really weird
I think about too because it's like if you have this truly artificially
intelligent thing,
they can access all the world's information like we can with Google,
uh,
and it can make its own decisions and has its own kind of sovereignty,
then it doesn't have sexual motivation.
So it's not even necessarily interested in looking good or making money.
It doesn't have like mortality motivation cause it,
if it backs up it's intelligence,
I could probably live forever.
Right.
So what motivates it to do anything?
Yeah,
there's no motivation.
That's an interesting thing.
People are worried that robots will take over and artificial intelligence will
dominate it.
It might just be a command line and like you type anything into it and it tells
you the answer or how it helps you out,
but it has just no interest in either harming humanity or helping us
unless it's a program that way.
The problem,
the real issue with artificial intelligence is if someone is so compelled to
create an artificial human being and gives us all of the components that a human
being has,
all the flaws as well,
emotions,
all the jealousy,
all the nonsense,
that'd be very bad.
Well,
if they don't have that,
then are they not a psychopath?
That's the problem.
I mean,
are you creating a complete psycho with no remorse and no compassion?
If you create an artificial person that's ruthlessly intelligent,
but it's not concerned whatsoever about pain and suffering and what if it's so
smart that it recognizes,
hey,
look,
people don't live forever anyway.
Like this is a moot point.
Like they're gonna die of old age,
which is one of the worst ways to go.
The last few years of your life,
your body's going to break down to the point you were ready to die because it's
sucks to be alive.
Like what's better that or we just eat them and use them for fuel to make a much
better race of robot,
artificial intelligent things that don't get jealous.
The matrix basically if that,
I mean,
you know,
I think that we're probably at least on the verge of a new member of our that
we're going to have to consider at the least if not our overlords.
I think this,
this idea of artificial intelligence is completely unavoidable.
It's just as unavoidable as the moment that the guy figured out a wagon wheel
and the other guy figured out an engine and he started going,
Huh,
Huh.
If we put that in there and get something to make those things,
how would you get the wheels to spin?
Um,
we need like a thing they're like connects to the,
and the injury was the engine making fire.
Yeah.
Burns shit.
We've got to get it bro.
Cause Burns gas.
So we got to get a tank that holds the gas.
It's inevitable.
It was just a matter of time before someone pieced all those things together.
When you're dealing with artificial intelligence,
like you know,
I mean even as simplistic form of it,
like Siri,
Siri's a form of artificial intelligence.
It's a database.
It's a,
it asks you ask it questions,
it provides you with the answers.
That's a form of something.
Doing some calculations.
When that starts becoming more and more complex and then they decide,
hey,
we want to recreate a human being.
Let's recreate memories.
We're going to program memories.
We're going to take someone's,
you know,
we're going to take.
What we did is we decided to take memories,
generic memories from happy people,
ages one through 60 and just create a 60 year old professor,
an artificial guy who's lived a long life of wisdom and we're going to have him
interact with people just to blow their fucking minds.
And meanwhile,
you know,
someone tells him,
you know that they made you just a week ago and he starts crying.
What about my children?
They don't exist.
Whoa.
Where'd my daughter was at her wedding.
It didn't happen.
It never happened.
You're a week old.
Oh,
we watched some fake 60 year old cry and then cut his throat.
He reaches in,
grabs on those straight razors from dollar shave done.
Fucking pointless because he realizes it sparks come flying out and then he
really freaks out and somebody goes,
there's no blood.
Somebody posts that article of the technology subreddit,
but it's instantly a removed and someone comes in and kicks his head off and
yells out.
Worldstar Worldstar in technology,
uh,
shows that as well.
And it becomes the number one video the internet ever sees ever.
And then he goes into porn robot porn with a sliced neck.
Cause this is Dick never goes soft as a fucking robot.
Once he learns he's a robot,
he just presses the dick hard button and it just goes,
I think that there's a real,
real concern at a certain point in time that we're going to create an artificial
thing that thanks for retarded.
Yeah.
If it's really doing your calculations and realizing like how ridiculous we are.
And it also might eliminate us because it goes,
okay,
if humans are allowed to continue surviving,
there's a nonzero chance that they will eventually wipe us out.
They'll either destroy the earth where they will for some reason,
decided to turn us off at some point.
And so because there's that non zero chance that they will eliminate us,
we have to eliminate them first and then you get like a Battlestar Galactica
kind of thing where they actually want
to kill humans just because they essentially live forever.
You know,
there's no time constraints,
so they don't want a situation where an 500 years,
we're so advanced that we were advanced,
that we decided that artificial intelligence is evil for some reason,
that we have some new religious leader and we turned it off.
Well,
the followers of Ted Kaczynski,
that's what it's going to be.
It's going to be the unibomber followers who said he's ahead of his time.
I mean,
that's what [inaudible] thought.
He thought that technology was our enemy.
It was the enemy of the human race.
And he was trying to actively stop technology by attacking and killing the
people that were responsible for innovation.
I mean,
it's a really crazy thought that may be in his wacky LSD mind that he had a
point that he really saw it all common and he saw he extrapolated the future and
he said,
oh my God,
we keep going along at this same rate.
There's not going to be any apple pie.
That's not going to be any Norman Rockwell paintings.
I think he was just a crazy person.
And I think a lot of crazy people,
uh,
can see like a very small part of the picture.
And that's why they're crazy.
They can see the little bit,
they can't see the whole fucking thing.
If they could see that,
they would be much less worried.
Do you know he was a part of the Harvard Lsd Studies,
right?
Um,
I did not know that.
You should look into it.
It's a fascinating,
there's a documentary called the net.
It's a foreign documentary in subtitles,
the net.
It's all,
uh,
documenting Ted Kaczynski.
He's part in the Harvard LSD studies where they just dose the shit out of kids
and found out what it did for them.
He went to Berkeley after that,
taught at Berkeley and used all of his money to fucking build this cabin in the
woods and then plot his war against civilization and,
and uh,
and,
and innovation.
Don't put that up.
We,
you can't,
don't put any more videos up unless I ask you to because these videos are
getting us pulled off of Youtube.
Movie preview won't do it.
I don't know about that man.
It's,
it's really annoying.
Lately we're getting like half of the videos we put up,
we get a something on youtube.
It says we shouldn't have it up.
It's the dispute if to do a fair use thing.
And we were talking about before,
you were talking about trolls that do that to videos.
Yeah.
Contents,
roles.
Uh,
they go through youtube videos and they'll tag stuff is being their copyright,
their property.
Even if it's just the video that I made in my apartment where the background is
my couch.
All of the words are my own words coming out of my own mouth for courted by me,
and this is what I sent to youtube.
Every time I get one of these complaints from these uh,
content troll companies,
I go,
how is it physically possible that they own any of this content?
Right.
And what do they respond to you?
They always end up reversing it,
but it takes me time to do that.
And what they're hoping is that a certain percentage of people won't take the
time and then they make a small amount of money off your videos.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
That's really fascinating that someone's decided to be that much of a cunt,
that they're going to pretend that you and your in your,
your office or wherever you're doing this thing that you somehow or another or
stealing their work.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Well,
I'm using English words and I think they probably use English words,
so it must be a copyright infringement.
Oh,
that's amazing.
It's amazing that they think that they can do that or that they think that
somehow or another that's justified.
Do you think they're randomly selecting people or they're purposely finding
people that have high number of videos?
High number of use.
If I were to say anything and just be complete speculation,
I don't know what they're going for,
but maybe it's like an algorithm,
like maybe it's a Bot that searches out things and it's a moneymaking Bot.
Yeah.
I'm always fascinated by when you go to a website and you're entering in
information,
they give you that weird scrambled letter thing that you have to decipher,
oh the capture scan.
This is the best way you have to do this.
And My,
by the way,
sometimes it's like tests that test the whole bunch.
Like when they crammed the letters together and I guess I'm not human cause I
didn't pass your fucking test.
You know?
Sometimes it's a real,
it's a real calculation.
I think it's a cue.
What that is that a g or a fucking Q?
What is that weird ass thing that doesn't look like a font?
You know?
I think when they just ask questions like,
you know,
what was the first president of the United States or something like that that,
that,
yeah,
that's,
that's a lot smarter.
Yeah.
But if you're a Google type database or you can have the algorithm go to Google
and answer the question,
like if you say something into Google,
it has it in a 10th of a second.
So if you have a direct connection and so it could get,
just get the answer and answer for,
you would look at the text and then have former response.
You can,
you know,
you could ask a Google search engine a question,
it'll take you to wiki answers and then boom.
So all we'd have to do is just print that.
Yeah.
But then it would be like,
it wouldn't be a one word answer.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like,
uh,
like it would be,
would it be who was the first president?
United States.
George Washington.
Yeah.
But if we're were to search,
Google would probably be like,
George Washington is a,
like,
it wouldn't know to just stop,
I guess.
Maybe,
you know what I mean?
Do you remember that thing?
Wolfram Alpha that they were doing a long time ago at any math search engine or
something?
Yeah,
well,
it was a search engine,
like an academic search search engine,
and I think the idea was to have a total complete human database.
Siri,
that's what it is.
It becomes Siri.
Yeah.
They use the technology for Siri works eight out of 10 times only.
Right?
It doesn't it?
I find,
I don't use it that often,
but I find it to be pretty accurate,
but I mean even good now is eight out of 10 right?
Two out of 10 it depends.
[inaudible].
Okay,
let's find out.
Let's Google this.
How often does Siri work?
Let's just say that.
And they remember when,
they don't want to say Siri,
the porn star,
because he's a porn star name.
Siri.
Do you remember when they were like cheesy infomercials on about that software
product where you'd put on the microphone and instead of typing it would read
your words and you'd be able to type a document that way?
Say that again.
What is it?
There used to be infomercials for this software where you'd put on the
microphone and instead of typing,
dragging,
dragging like speech recognition and then it was so clunky
that what we have now is ridiculously better than like anything that I think
they expect it.
Yeah.
Well I'm,
I have a friend who used to write all of his books with that.
He used to,
yeah,
he's put headphones on and walk around his apartment years ago and he actually
used windows because the windows version of dragon was way better than the Mac
version.
That was a very reason why he did it.
He did all of his writing through rants and then he would go back over it and
then edit it and try to figure it out.
But it was like,
to capture my words is,
is accurately with my fingers.
Like I just,
I can't type that fast.
There's no way it felt like there was something missing in the flow of his
ideas.
I've always had the opposite opinion.
I think that I write better because,
um,
when I actually physically use the keyboard,
because I am giving a lot of thought and consideration to each one of these
words because it takes me a lot longer to type out the word consideration than
it does to have that concept in my mind.
That concept in my mind goes in and out and there's,
there's both like the rants that you would come up with an a podcast,
you probably would never,
you'd never write that way because you're in sort of this frantic flowing thing
where one idea feeds into the next and this steam behind them.
But when you're writing and you're really considering every single sentence and
going back over it and going back over the is,
that's the best way to phrase this.
Like a Hemingway,
is this as concise as possible?
Could I go shorter?
Yeah.
Is it,
there's a way to put more flare to it.
There's a way to,
you know,
give it a better feeling.
Like what's the impact that I'm going to get from reading?
This is a way to enhance that in some way,
that extra consideration.
I think is good.
It's not that you can't do that in the editing process though,
but for me it's silence is how I write best.
I don't want to even hear my own voice.
I don't want to hear shit most of the time.
Don't listen to music unless there's are a rare moment.
But the idea that you could just talk a whole email and absolutely have it be
perfect,
that's really compelling.
Like it was like day to day tasks that weren't like creative.
It's so good.
You don't have to check it before you send it to your boss.
Like,
Hey,
Dave is 1230 on Wednesday.
Okay for a podcast question mark,
send,
boom,
done.
Takes five seconds.
I do that all the time with text messaging.
By the way,
one of the things about androids is,
um,
they're,
uh,
they're Google voice software that they use for analyzing,
um,
uh,
analyzing your texts.
Like if I send you a text,
it's fucking incredible.
It's really,
really accurate.
Cool.
It's really accurate.
It's really fast.
It picks it up as you're talking and you could see the,
the letters for me.
And that's just on a cell phone.
They're also not shitheads about accepting stuff into their APP store.
So much more open environment.
Yeah.
Despite what everybody's been telling me,
no,
there are no bitcoin applications available for the iPhone.
You may have a bitcoin application for the iPhone,
but you cannot new ones.
That's what people are saying,
like,
oh,
I have a big coin.
If you don't know what you're talking about.
Well,
and then two,
because you already downloaded,
they're trying to download one right now.
You're not gonna be able to get it.
There are apps that will show you the price and stuff,
but there aren't apps that will allow you to send or receive bitcoins.
That's fascinating.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing.
Well,
is there any rational explanation for why apple is chosen to do that?
I think,
I mean there are two reasons.
One is that they make a tremendous amount of money from saving your credit card
info and then every time you decide you want to buy a song or you want to buy an
APP,
it goes through their system.
And I think they're worried that if they open up the flood gates to Bitcoin,
they lose that 30% that they're making.
That's a very good point.
So that even think of that because apple is,
that's a huge part of their businesses that I didn't get store.
Yeah.
They give APP developers I believe 70% and they take 30 and with bitcoin they be
getting like nothing.
That is a very good point in a very likely reason.
That's a very likely motivation.
The other reason is just they're worried about legal shit.
Uh,
but that's not so much concerned because if a company like apple wants to do
something,
they do it.
They always have,
you know,
the ability to,
yeah.
Remain compliant and that's what they would do.
That's a really good point,
man.
I didn't even think of that,
but I bet you're dead right.
With their iTunes store for movies,
the iTunes store for music,
that's probably a considerable chunk of revenue that could very well be swept
away with bitcoin.
If someone came up with an application that allowed artists to sell their music
directly with bit coin,
no iTunes and then someone ma manages a another application that ports it into
into iTunes.
Well we're going to,
we're going to see some really weird stuff in the next couple of years.
We're going to see banks where it's just a bunch of bitcoin users funding the
bank and then the bank decides who to loan money to and so then like you'll have
a situation where instead of going to chase or wells Fargo,
you'll just go to like the guide on the street who owns his own community bank
and there'll be run by bitcoin so you know that the money he claims he has is
actually there because you can verify it.
It's getting the picture in five years is going to look so weird compared to
today.
The idea of driving up to an ATM machine in five years is going to be the same
as walking into a blockbuster and picking up a VHS tape.
It's just not going to be something people need to do.
So you think that all money will be digital currency in a certain amount of
time?
Yeah.
God,
I realize it's a kind of a bold prediction,
but you get to a point where there's no turning back and it's the same with,
uh,
how many people own analogue TV still for a while it was kind of like 20% owned
flat screen HDTV is 80% still had the old tubes.
Yeah.
And then slowly over time,
more and more,
your friends got the flat screens until eventually,
even your friends who don't have any money and are not up on tech trends,
you walk into their house and it's a brand new Samsung.
What happened there?
Analog always loses out to digital.
That seems to be the trend in anything.
Well,
innovation always stumps out the old stupid shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
I can't guarantee the bitcoin will be the first one.
And in fact it's possible that it won't be the one that that takes off finally,
because
if you look at operating systems,
it was xerox labs created one of the first visual operating systems and Steve
jobs was taking a tour of the Xerox Park because they had told him like,
you get to check this out,
it's really cool.
It's up your alley.
He saw that took one look at it and it was like,
this is what I should be doing at apple.
Took that idea,
made the visual Apple Macintosh,
whatever the fuck it was,
the opera graphic user interface,
that's what they invented,
invented the point and click the trash bin and dragging files instead of a
command line.
So,
but even apple wasn't.
So that was the second generation.
Even that wasn't the one that took off because apple for a long time was only
used by a subset of designers and writers and stuff.
It was actually windows.
It was the third one where Bill Gates saw,
uh,
with Steve jobs had done and he goes,
we got to make windows,
we'll make it a little bit cheaper and make it a little bit simpler for people
to use.
Doesn't have to be as beautiful,
but we're going for the mass market.
And that's the one that took off and I think be the same situation with this,
where bitcoin blazed the trail and maybe it'll always have a place in the same
way that apple is always had a place and now it's a very big place.
So we'll have like multiple alternative currencies to choose from.
Yeah,
it's going to be really weird.
You're going to have like three or four currencies and you're going to use them
for different things.
Like if you're tipping,
if you're tipping a podcast,
you might use a bitcoin,
but if you're at a strip club,
you might use some other coin for some other reason.
And you know what someone's got to do though.
Someone's got to make it treason.
If you interfere with this,
like if you try to sabotage these digital currencies and stop innovation because
you're,
you're worried that your whatever company you're doing,
whatever thing you're doing is going to somehow or another be impacted by it
should be treasonous.
They like the idea that you could come in like they're,
and I've government agents that are coming in and sabotaging bitcoin buying and
selling and stealing the IRS.
The IRS has already ruled that it's property.
So if you have any government agency that tries to damage the,
um,
the network,
then you're damaging your own citizens property.
And that is illegal.
That's one of the most basic tenants of American capitalism is we protect
property rights here.
Like it might not happen in countries in South America that you get a new
dictator,
everybody's property gets taken over.
That's not what America does.
We actually respect property rights.
So it's very strange to me that we would have people even think about
challenging that.
Well,
if that's the case,
then what's going on with this mount Gox thing and that means is a giant grand
theft took place for $300 million in property was stolen.
That was a,
that was a fat dumb ass who programmed his site and the wrong language and got a
lot of market share because he was one of the first people there.
And uh,
if you look at just traditional money,
US dollars in euros,
it attracts a lot of criminals,
you know,
surprise when you're dealing with billions of dollars.
The kinds of people who are attracted to that,
some of them are honest,
some of them are not.
And how many failures have we had within the dollar?
We had a,
what was it,
Lehman Brothers went under,
bear Stearns had to be bought out by chase for like pennies on the dollar or
like two bucks a share or something.
And uh,
we had Bernie made off like scams related to money or nothing new and that's not
going to go away with bitcoin.
It's just that now we're going to have a little bit more accountability.
And I personally just like to see these old fucks in Davos.
I like to see them sweat a little bit for the first time because they have given
my generation more than a trillion dollars of student loan debt that we can't
pay off.
And when I say we,
I'm just talking about everybody.
I don't have any student loan debt,
but they've done that.
We're all pretty much indentured servants to the Zombie banks,
which if you look into them as people like Matt Taibbi had done their semi
insolvent,
they are corrupt to the core,
they are politically entrenched and they're not efficient.
That's what bothers me.
Like all the other shit is all well and good.
It's just not efficient.
Like I used to be in credit cards,
I had a credit card website where it would rank deals for people and I honestly
believe that the time that plastic is the best way to buy things more efficient
than cash.
You have a record of it.
So you know,
come tax time what you spent on business stuff.
When this came around,
I instantly realized,
Oh okay,
credit cards days are numbered.
It might not be an,
you know,
it might take a year,
it might take five years,
but they're done.
So
yeah,
I think,
um,
digital currency without a doubt,
threatens the paradigm.
It,
it threatens the,
the situation that they have,
the,
the strangle hold they have.
And once you see companies like tiger direct starting to sell computers and
different Vegas casinos are starting to accept it,
overstocks a huge company and they accept it.
Yeah.
It's going to get weird.
It's going to get real weird.
I'm,
I'm really curious to see what happens and really curious to see what the blow
back is going to be.
What sort of federal attack on a bitcoin and you have a really good point that
there's always been corruption as far as regular money goes,
far as accepted,
conventional money goes.
There's always been massive amounts of corruption.
There's always been massive amounts of theft was always been problems,
but no one has said we can't have money anymore.
Everybody's corrupt.
Bernie Madoff fucked it up.
No more money.
Yeah.
How many people,
right?
Rubber checks.
That's something that never happens with bitcoin.
I can't send you a rubber Bitcoin,
I can't send you a fake bitcoin.
That's a real good point.
And so like just,
if you ignore all the political implications and that's all you focus on,
like do you want to have a technology where there's a really good chance of
chargeback fraud,
which is the case with credit cards or a rubber check with checks.
Uh,
do you want that or do you want the thing where there's zero chance of that
consumers eventually,
I don't know when it's going to happen.
It might not even be this year.
Consumers over time,
once they tire of the propaganda they're seeing on TV,
we'll go,
well yeah,
I want the one where it's 100% certain,
I don't want the one where I don't know what the fuck's happening
three days.
So this is Mt.
Gox guy fucked up and courted coded his site and a shitty way when all that
money's gone,
all that $300 million in Bitcoin is gone.
Our people investigating that like it's a crime.
I mean are they should be.
I'm sure they are.
I think the US wants to drag his ass over here.
Is he an American?
Uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what he is.
I know his company was based in Japan.
It looks like he's an American.
He doesn't,
he doesn't look Asian.
Um,
the,
the Mt Gox thing though is if,
if,
if that is property,
that's a huge piece of theft.
I mean it should be something that prosecutors go after.
Is it one of those gray areas where he's looking around going,
what's a crime taking place here?
Oh,
I think they're going to go after him.
I think that he's going to be one of the examples that the government makes is
like,
you can't do this.
This is fucked up.
You can't do it because there's actually a lot of money,
uh,
that's supposed to go into bitcoin over the summer.
Institutional money.
When a second market comes online,
which is supposed to be like the first really credible exchange that big banks
would be comfortable using.
But here's a big,
fat,
stupid head.
It looks like he ate some bitcoins and all the big crazy
$300 million in bitcoins.
Mt.
Gox is set to liquidate as court denies rehabilitation,
so they're going to liquidate.
Now what does that mean?
Once the world's biggest beer?
This is seven hours ago.
This came out once the world's biggest bitcoin exchange.
Mt.
Gox is likely to be liquidated after a Tokyo court dismissed the companies bid
to resuscitate it's business.
The court appointed administrator court appointed administrative set on
Wednesday Mark Carr pile less Karpeles cyclists is also likely to be
investigated for liability and the collapse of the Tokyo based from the
provisional administrator.
Lawyer no bull.
Aki Kobiashi said in a settlement,
a statement published on the Mt.
Gox Whiteside.
Look at that big fat stupid head.
He looks so dumb too.
He doesn't just look like a an overweight guy.
He looks like a dunce.
Nice hair.
Bad.
Well,
I mean he'd racy jumped from what magic the gathering to managing one of the
most high traffic exchanges in the world.
Yeah.
What does that guy going to do for a job after this?
I mean,
if he has any money at all,
people are gonna find it and go give me that pitch.
Fucking my bitcoins.
Smack him in the head.
Oh,
I'm sure he has a lot of people who are not happy with them.
You better stay over there man.
By the way,
a all my kind of political rabble rousing about how bitcoin will change the
landscape.
I just want to put in a um,
kind of disclaimer that in five years you might still see chase and bank of
America because there's a chance that if they see it taking off fast enough,
they'll adopt it because for them it's just the new payment technology like they
use visa and mastercard.
They could just as easily issue a bitcoin debit card and base it off of that
network and find a way to make money off of it by providing people,
you know,
the security of your not dealing with some fat ass.
In Japan,
you're dealing with Bank of America,
you're dealing with chase.
That's possible.
But one thing that's very clear is that it's going to be completely different
print
and a couple of years.
Yeah,
I think you're absolutely right.
Fascinating stuff,
man.
This is such an interesting time to be alive because there's so much going on
and there's so much change and there's so many people that are wondering like,
which way is it going to go?
And people that are looking at it in a negative way,
people that are looking at it,
it promising,
you know,
um,
well what's really cool to think about if you look at,
uh,
where a lot of the money came from in Silicon Valley for these really innovative
companies we're seeing today,
it started with paypal where Peter Teal and a Ilan mosque,
I think a couple of other guys,
Max something made billions of dollars off of their paypal venture because
paypal was at the time a challenge to the status quo.
It was,
you don't need an expensive merchant.
Uh,
uh,
whatever that thing was that merchants had to have,
um,
to process credit cards,
a merchant account,
you don't need that.
All you need is an email address and we verify some stuff,
link it to your bank account,
and now you have a form of digital money.
And,
uh,
that was 15 years ago.
So we're overdue for kind of a new,
a challenge to the status quo.
And my point is that when paypal happened,
it made a lot of people rich and that money ended up getting invested in things
that have nothing to do with currency.
It was invested in a Tesla and space x and all these next generation companies.
And we will probably see the same thing.
Now we'll see people get rich off of this and then that money,
since they're young and not compromise old people will go into really bizarre
things where the dividend is just going to be massive.
Um,
what I was getting at is that
there's a lot of folks that look at the possibilities in the future and look at
all and they,
they see only negative.
And as a very unfortunate,
and um,
that was our friend Michael Rupert,
um,
who he,
uh,
somehow or another a couple of days ago committed suicide,
by a gunshot.
Allegedly.
There's,
I'm sure there's a lot of people out there think he was murdered.
Uh,
there always is going to be on those things.
But I know he wasn't a happy guy.
And,
uh,
if you look at the way he looked at the world,
I mean everything he saw,
he saw that movie collapse.
It's him sitting there,
chain smoking,
talking about the end.
And it's incredibly compelling cause he was a very articulate guy.
He was very,
he was very believable.
He was charismatic,
he was passionate and he knew a lot of things.
Um,
his version was the sky is falling and you know,
he's wrong about a lot of things.
He was wrong about a lot of predictions.
He was wrong about a lot of his thoughts on peak oil and a lot of other things
that he thought were going to come to a conclusion in our,
you know,
in just the last decade and just fuck everything up.
And it didn't happen.
Um,
I found out about him from a book that he had put out.
Oh,
crossing the Rubicon is a long time ago and it was all about same sort of thing.
Just,
it's always,
it was always negative.
It was always doom and it was always gloom and he wasn't well the last few years
of his life and apparently decided to end it on his own terms.
So,
um,
it's unfortunate.
I really liked that guy.
He was a sweetie.
He was a really cool guy to be around who's fun and it was warm.
It's friendly,
like the hug people.
It was just,
it was a real nice guy to be around.
It was unfair.
I mean,
I enjoyed doing podcasts with him too.
He was a,
I enjoy to him,
I didn't see the doom and gloom.
I didn't see that side of the way he did and I didn't agree with them on things,
but he was a very pleasant guy to be around and I'm going to miss him.
Sucks.
Sorry to hear about that.
It's a,
you know,
it sucks when people look,
I mean,
look,
I don't know what sucks more going on when you're miserable as fuck or ending it
and your own shirt,
you should always go on because the circumstances always change.
So Ab,
but hunter s Thompson was done.
Well that's the thing about that guy.
A lot of his issue,
I think it was physical pain and that's different.
That's one of the,
um,
not that I have any say of what people do or really even care,
but that's one of the,
for me morally,
it's where I think that suicide is okay.
Like if you're in so much pain and you've pursued every avenue and modern
medicine can't help you reduce that pain and it's physical pain rather than just
mental pain,
then I don't really have a problem with.
And I think,
and even in Switzerland now,
there some kind of assisted suicide program and I think we gotta be humane.
Like if we put down an animal because it's in a lot of pain,
why can't we let an old guy do the same thing?
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
There's definitely a time where you should be able to end it on your own terms.
Why should someone have to like choke on their own blood until their lungs fill
up.
Let people die with dignity.
You know,
like at a certain point like if the cancer treatment failed or whatever it is,
give that person a choice.
I agree and it's another thing we're,
why should someone be able to tell you what to do?
Y I mean the idea that it's illegal.
It's hilarious anyway.
You're going gonna lock him in jail after he kills himself.
I mean it's stupid.
It's stupid to make suicide illegal.
We need way more mental health counseling everywhere.
We need a lot more thought into whatever it is.
It's wrong with people that causes them to be massively depressed.
A lot more thought into is it just the way we live our lives?
Is it just the idea of s sitting in some fucking office doing some mundane job
that you hate being stuck in this traffic where you feel completely out of
control.
You don't have any control over your environment.
Just stuck and this massive people who are also doing the same thing.
And you look around and no one seems to be happy.
Is it just that,
I mean,
is that something we need to fix?
Is the idea of cities are,
these are these ridiculous ideas that we should abandon condensed humans to a
neatly packed area?
Does that make us crazy?
Are we even designed for it?
There's all these things it needs to be considered.
There's a lot of what we're doing is not well thought out.
It was a lot of what we're doing in society that's not,
not the most intelligent,
innovative,
creative way to go about it.
Yeah,
I,
uh,
I agree,
but I think that a lot of these problems have always been a part of the human
experience and we just have to learn how to deal with it and get each other
through it.
Because I don't,
I don't think the Pr,
I used to think like,
Oh,
if I want to be happier,
I have to just reduce the amount of stress in my life,
but things I'm doing I enjoy doing.
And as a byproduct,
they're stress.
Like,
you know,
like I enjoy putting out controversial articles that make people think about
things.
The result of that is somebody in the comments section calls me up cock sucker,
you know,
like that's how it goes.
And I'm not willing to not write the article because of the stress.
So,
uh,
I think that instead of eliminating all the problems,
we just have to be there for each other and a lot of people feel isolated.
And that's where you get these,
um,
tragedies is people no longer have anybody else to do the feedback loop because
a lot of shit is like,
if that,
I don't know anything about that guy,
so I don't want to speak as if I do.
But if he had somebody who could tell him,
you know,
yeah,
that's terrible what you're saying about the government.
But 2000 years ago they were crucifying people and now they just drag activists
through the court system.
And I'm not saying that's a good thing.
You don't want to put people in jail and bullshit charges.
It's a little bit better than crucifying people you don't like.
And if you look at the trend that humanities on,
it's an improving trend.
It's impossible not to see that like the mouth and model of human behavior and
human existence has been proven false.
Like when you get higher population,
you don't get people starving and destruction.
You get more innovation because there are more minds coming together and you get
things that you didn't even think were possible.
Like right now,
we don't have a serious food crisis in the first world anyways because we've
always been able to scale the technology.
We have more people and then we get better at farming and then we have more
people and they create more innovation which leads to better farming and so on.
No,
I,
I completely agree.
I hate that Malthusian that's great word by the way.
I hate,
I hate that approach.
It's lazy.
Yeah.
I think if you really do objective,
we look at it,
there's a lot of good shit about human beings today.
I mean,
it's one of the best times ever to be alive.
It's certainly scary.
There's certainly we're,
there's a lot of potential for disaster.
There's a lot of potential for catastrophe that's manmade man created,
whether it's nuclear or war or whatever it is.
It could be po
terror.
I think it was on one of your podcasts recently where you said that the
Fukushima response,
they covered it up like a little child.
He had done something wrong.
Yeah,
they swept it under the rug.
That's really,
that's what they do.
And it's the same thing with the BP oil spill.
Like when that happened,
we just watched it like a kid watching the milk falling off of a table after you
spill your cereal,
how long do we fucking watch that thing on CNN and nobody really did anything.
And then finally they came in and like tried to clamp it and took days and
you're just watching it spill out.
They should have imploded that thing on day one,
which they didn't want to do cause they would have lost a lot of revenue.
Yeah,
they probably should have fit.
Well they wanted to launch on nuke at it.
Right.
And just blow the whole thing up.
Another bad idea because the idea wasn't that one of the ideas of blowing it up
that way it would seal the well somehow or another.
Well,
there's also like there are all these beautiful parts of the world that have
been radiated from our nuclear tests.
Back when we didn't know what we were doing,
it was like the French military in the u s military.
We're just picking beautiful deserted islands,
which today would be worth know today
would be the places that Richard Branson hangs out in.
But instead they're just these desolate test sites.
It's so gross and dumb that we did that in the first place.
Have you ever seen that animated Gif of all of the nuclear explosions that have
gone off in the world?
Uh,
no.
Last time you showed me,
I think population population,
all the numbers coming in.
That's pretty crazy.
That's a crazy thing to see like,
and the little flags behind them.
How many people being born?
Britain,
Japan,
China,
the bombs being blown up since the 1940s to the present.
All the nuclear test.
It's fucking crazy.
I was thought there was like four or five,
like how many times do we need to blow these fucking things up before we realize
what they do now there's a lot.
What are they learning?
Can you just model this on a computer?
Even 50 years ago they had computers and you can go,
oh,
okay,
so this rocket's moving at this speed.
You know like we can plug the rest in and figure it out.
We don't actually have to launch the rocket to figure out if it's gonna work or
not.
Tell you what day would see him and I'm from Missouri.
Missouri is the show.
May state you want,
you want to sell me one of your nuclear weapons.
Look up at the big screen here we see the first one.
This is like 1945 there it says up there,
boom,
that's it.
Manhattan project.
Here we go,
bitches.
Boom.
1945 again,
drop another one.
1945 Nagasaki,
boom.
One more.
Then you see all of the nuclear tests and that's when it gets really squirly.
The two that were used in war combined with the one that was used to figure out
if it fucking works and look at these in the ocean.
They just let a couple up because a film in the ocean and 47 and then in the the
19th and 48 like the 50s like that one,
two,
three boom,
boom,
boom.
I mean it was so far we're up to how many?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Eight for United States,
one for Russia.
So the u s is winning us is winning is still good?
Yeah,
we're way with Russia.
Russia's like that crazy.
Look at this.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
We just,
now we have 17 by 1951 24 we have 32 33 boom,
boom,
boom cannon.
A bunch go off in the [inaudible]
desert.
Look at,
look at how many would blow up in Nevada.
The reason why gambling
legal right there.
By the way,
I liked the one random one in Australia.
They're like,
yeah,
we're good.
Let me figure it.
Australia.
Russia just blows off a couple more.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
So we're up
the United States up to 70 87 by 1956 we're up to 87 nuclear blasts on hundred
and 17 by 58
yeah,
mutated or the people in that little area.
By the end of 58 we get up to 196 by the end of 58
damn.
There's a lot in California.
Is that California or is that Nevada?
It looked like California and at the end,
I didn't know there were any in California.
Yeah,
it does look very California,
doesn't it?
Yeah,
it's like million.
Look at all of them.
Three Oh to look at this.
331 nuclear explosions by 63 there's no way those are nukes that's got it.
Wow,
you're wrong.
They gotta be testing out some kind of technology that they're blown up.
Nukes.
That is insane.
They're lightened them bitches up like a Christmas tree and that's why you can
get that $4 steak and eggs breakfast in Vegas.
We wonder,
we wonder why everybody has cancer.
They're up to 580590600 blast by 69
by 1969 bro,
by the end of 69 it's up to 663 blacks.
Nixon gets in there and he's like,
we've got to really accelerate things.
Pick up pump.
The Russians are on our tail.
Damn.
Look at Britain.
Britain stops.
It's 26 I think we're good.
What's so,
what's so weird about this?
It seems like the u s did it and then Russia is like,
we got it too.
And it could have stopped there,
but we just kept going and going and finally rush is like,
all right,
we got to get in also.
Well this was the Cold War Man.
I mean,
I'm sure Russia had the same sort of motivation.
Yeah.
As far as their contractors and the people that were charging dumb idea,
mutually assured destruction,
like all these military ideas from 40 years ago,
we now know are completely ridiculous.
But to look at where it
sat,
it's pull up,
pull back so we can see the numbers,
Brian.
Okay.
What did you do?
Pull back.
So you're not on the thing.
Yeah,
it's the animation is making me have to Piss,
so,
oh my God.
So animation of all nuclear explosions from 1945 to 1998 and at the end of 1998
it gets to 1032 nuclear explosions just from the Unites States of America.
715 from Russia,
210 from,
what does that,
what does that look?
What fucking
great.
France.
France has a lot of nuclear explosions.
Is that France?
What is the blue?
White and red?
Yeah.
We supposed to know that is that Mexico is for Jesus Christ.
Mexico has four for China's 45 who's the one on the far left?
Some hippie thing.
Moon and a star.
Green and white.
That's like an Arab country.
Yeah.
Wow.
Pakistan,
India and Pakistan.
That's what that is.
India has for Pakistan as to Jesus Christ.
That's scary.
It's really scary is how much was on our side of the coast.
You know,
like I don't even,
yeah,
we're nuclear cannot be good.
Maybe it's great.
Maybe that's why California is awesome.
What does it found out that like a little bit of radiation is fucking super good
for you and it makes really smart people get it.
And the lack of the lack of nuclear radiation that they have and like New Jersey
is what's the real problem?
They need to detonate a couple nukes in New Jersey and fucking straightened
everybody out.
I'm like,
oh,
now we get it.
We just need a little,
uh,
just
a little bit of radiation in the air.
I used to think that maybe cigarettes were probably,
I was when I was competing,
I think that cigarettes may be like a workout for your lungs,
that if you could,
if you could lift a little weights with your lungs,
but like if he smoked cigarettes that your lungs and have to like fight against
that,
the cigarette smoke.
And it'd be like lifting weights to dumbest idea I've ever had,
but it's not too far off from those like air trainers like those,
uh,
those oxygen things where they,
you're supposed to suck on those like boss route and had that air trainer h two
o trainer.
It's your air intake,
right?
Yeah,
I don't think those work man is a guy who a mock them.
Um,
but then I saw hypoxia,
like there was a Victor Conte video on Hypoxia,
which is real similar.
They do doing like heavy a high endurance training,
high intensity and Durrance training and they do it with like restricted
breathing.
So I don't know who was right about that.
Altitude is supposed to be where it's at,
like sleeping in the altitude,
but,
but working out in an area where it's got plenty of oxygen so that,
that seems contrary to me because the idea is that not restrict your oxygen
intake while you're exercising,
but restricting it while you're resting.
That's what's supposed to be good.
Your body realizes like,
bitch,
we ain't going to the air up here.
And then it starts pumping out all these extra blood cells.
Hmm.
You see the article that uh,
they found a way to inject oxygen into somebody's body.
Yeah.
Keeps you from drowning for like 20 seconds.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
That's for now.
It's 20 seconds.
Who knows what it's going to be?
It's going to be like the abyss.
I was just thinking that we're going to have the abyss suits where it fills up
with liquid and we can go down to the bottom.
That movie kicked ass until the very end.
The very end.
They ruined the whole mood when you see what the thing looks like.
But space ship.
Uh Yup.
Dumb fucking toys.
Irs thing that comes out of the water and you're like,
what?
That's not a spaceship.
That's why I liked the movies where the director has disciplined to leave it to
your imagination.
It's hard though.
People,
people are dumb.
Yeah,
we're rolling through the whole,
I move that land on the moon where you are even know.
I mean was there a Werewolf I didn't even get a good book to have.
It won't be able to see what it is.
Well that's like Jj Abrams.
I feel like he's always like a smoke moms.
He's got you like right on the edge of your seat and then you never get the
final.
You just want to know what he could make up anything.
You just want to know.
You want to have some kind of certainty and he doesn't give you that.
Well,
he gave me a smoke monster though.
He can go fuck himself with that fucking smoke monster.
Did you say that?
That today in California,
they're trying to figure out if they want to make,
uh,
the gray wolf and endangered specie in California.
I didn't even know there was great.
Wilson,
California.
Yeah.
Well,
Gray Wolf's.
Here's the issue with wolves,
and this is something that Steve,
a Rinella brought up.
They're exactly the same.
Like wolves everywhere.
It's all this one species of wolf,
but that's the same with humans.
And some wolves are bigger,
just like some humans are bigger.
If you brought a bunch of Germans,
big giant German
people,
and then imported them into Japan,
they started dominating and people said,
well,
hey,
it's the same species.
We just brought people from another place.
It's the same thing.
No,
no.
You're changing the environment by bringing in these much larger versions of
what used to exist here and the wolves that you're seeing in like Yellowstone,
these reintroduced wolves,
they're from Canada and they're big.
They're like 150 plus pounds.
Big But polite.
No,
they're rude.
They kill a lot of animals.
But the,
the wolves that used to be in North America,
we're smaller.
See,
there's a thing that happens in,
uh,
with um,
mammals and it has to do with the amount of cold these mammals have to
experience.
And the more cold they have to experience,
the larger their body sizes.
That's why polar bears are so fucking big and you go to like d dear is a perfect
example.
Deer in Mexico have much smaller bodies.
Then deer in Canada,
deer and Canada,
like in Alberta and all these Saskatchewan giant deer,
the 300 plus pounds,
some of the big males,
the big bucks.
But if you take a deer that's the same age and it's in Mexico,
it might only be a hundred pounds.
So the further north you go,
the more the animal needs to generate heat from body mass.
I wonder if that's why whales are so big because they go so deep that they're in
a super cold,
like barely freezing kind of thing.
Right.
It makes sense.
It's a mammal.
I mean,
this is something that they've attributed to this reason why grizzly bears and
polar bears are so big.
It's like as you get north,
the the same species of animal tends to be larger.
Pretty fascinating stuff,
man.
Pretty fascinating and completely make sense with these Canadian wolves because
their biggest fuck.
Whereas the American wolves were smaller.
They just were always like,
you know,
60 70 pounds,
whatever.
So when they brought over these big ass fucking wolves from Canada and they have
that DNA in them,
the big Ass Wolf Dna,
these just decimating elk and deer populations in an areas where they're at and
they've re-instituted hunting on them now that,
so they brought them in and now they've got hunting and trapping and people in
Alaska and a lot of parts of North America where they have a lot of wolves.
They have wolf season now you can go hunting wolves.
I could never shoot something that's a dog.
Yeah,
it's going to go whoa.
Oh yes you could.
I could do a bear.
I could do almost anything else.
Can't do a dog.
You couldn't do a dog if it was coming after you eat your family.
If I had to,
uh,
listen man,
if you were a rancher and you watched a super PAC like they've had in Siberia,
Siberia hasn't legitimate wolf problem and Siberia at one point in time,
you know the story of World War One,
the wolf a thing,
the Germans and the Russians,
they call us a cease fire.
Wolves caused a cease fire because so many of the soldiers were getting killed
by wolves.
As I said,
hey,
hey.
They ran into a super PAC and while they were,
the two armies were connecting with each other while they were exchanging,
they would send out like scouts,
scouts get eaten by wolves and so they would find like these bodies like,
you know,
with their boots on and the a foot and the boot,
and the,
everything else is just smashed and destroyed and they realize there's these big
ass wolf bill wolf type stuff.
Yeah,
it's fascinating because they actually had a meeting and they,
you know,
they said,
okay,
let's truce ceasefire.
Let's go kill these fucking wolves.
Then we'll go back to killing each other.
So they had a cease fire,
killed all the walls and then went back to war.
It's crazy.
But,
but that can happen with wolves.
Wolves can develop super pacs and a in Siberia they started taking out horses
and farm animals and they would go a hundred wolf strong and just invade a farm
and good fucking luck stomp.
And um,
they figured out a way to get over the fences and then they would just go crazy.
When things get collaborative,
you get a lot more power.
It's like the same as dolphins.
One Dolphin can't do anything but a whole pack of them can kill a shark,
I think.
Yeah.
Well dolphins are really good at at least fucking sharks up.
Orchids kill sharks on irregular orchids.
They're so smart.
They figured out how to kill sharks the easy way.
Like they,
you know,
they can communicate with each other and talk.
We don't know what they're saying,
but we know they're talking,
they figured it out.
How to pass the knowledge from generation to generation that the way to kill a
shark is you bite it.
And then you flip it upside down when you flip a shark upside down were like
really old designs.
Their designs suck.
It's like God got to them and it was like he wasn't really good at making shit.
Then it's like old cars like try driving like a 1970,
you know Plymouth,
their suspensions,
dog shit,
their breaks suck.
No seatbelts.
Steering is so vague.
You don't know what it's transmitted.
Their dog shit cars.
That's what a shark is.
The dog shit animal.
Like the design was terrible.
They have to keep moving and if you flip them upside down,
they just,
yeah,
they just bunk out and die.
So the org has grab them.
I just flip them upside down and hold on in women's around them and then they
eat them.
That's such a sign of intelligence that they found the cheat code to killing a
what would be their biggest predator?
Yeah,
that's the,
well that is the only Predator that they would have.
I mean,
they would have to worry about them around.
They're small,
they're cubs,
the babies.
But,
uh,
an Orca is like way smarter and more powerful than shark shark is just an idiot.
So the arc is the ORC is basically like a human being.
The shark,
the shark is almost like a biological robot in the same way that spiders are
like,
yes,
of any animal.
Spiders are the only one where I got curious and research them online.
And the more I read,
the less I liked them because normally like no matter what it is like,
Oh shit,
they can do that.
That's amazing.
And I got to the point where it was a video and it was the mating ritual of
jumping spiders and it's these,
it first I was like,
Oh shit,
I am going to like spiders because what they do to attract each other as the
male like pounds his,
uh,
legs on the ground and the sound vibrations,
I guess stimulate the female in some way and pull that.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so what happened in the video though is like,
um,
if I'm remembering correctly,
the male jumping spider,
it looks like he's going to get some and they zoom in on his eyes and you're
like,
oh,
like if the spider could be happy,
this spider is probably happy,
right?
Like,
and then it looks like the female was about to get mounted,
which it takes a big fucking bite out and like,
wow.
And then just jumps off and he jumps off in the other direction and you can see
the guts and like,
you know what?
Fuck spiders,
zero respect.
Because I was starting to think like,
I shouldn't kill spiders.
If I see them in my apartment,
I should leave them alone or let them take the time to let them out.
This is it.
I think,
okay,
we'll get these little bastards.
Well,
they're evil.
They have no morals.
The robots,
they don't know how to seek out protein.
Yeah.
And they have venom.
They're,
they're,
they're creepy.
I mean,
just the idea of black widows,
a Saml necrosis is such a dick move.
Like it's not bad enough that you love to bite.
You got to like the whole thing's got to rot out over time and some of them can
kill a person pretty easy.
Like there's,
there's certain spiders like um,
those brown recluses that just do unbelievable damage with one of their stings.
If you want to never go into the woods again or ever leave your apartment,
just do a Google image search for reckless
bites.
Yeah,
they're horrible.
The necrosis aspect of it is one of the grossest things.
It just causes all the flesh to die around the wound.
Yeah.
Oof.
I don't know.
This is the one that I saw because I didn't,
I don't remember there being captions,
but it's the same idea cause this is what they do to attract each other,
but there's a good chance whenever they do this ritual that the female will
choose to eat the mail.
And that right there is a sign of insanity to me.
I think emails larger all the time.
He's trying to fuck you and show you a good time with his leg dance and you tear
his,
his abdomen out.
Well,
the matriarchal society,
it's like common in bugs.
It's in ants.
You know an answer.
There's a lot of female ants that the queen,
they kill the,
uh,
the males and they deal with the way they breathe with them.
They cut his wings off,
they cut his legs off and they take them into the hive and breed with them
there.
And he said,
it doesn't even look as a jumping spider.
It doesn't even look real horrible.
So strange looking.
There's actually a meme.
It's like misunderstood spider.
And uh,
he's like,
oh great,
what are you doing over there?
He's like,
you,
you bitch.
You just sprayed me and his eyes.
What a creepy fucking bug.
It's weird.
The same world that evolved,
that thing also evolved us.
I watched a video the day,
I didn't know kingsnakes were so gangster because you know,
king snakes have no venom.
So I always thought like,
king snakes are just like gardens next.
Oh No,
no,
no.
King snakes eat rattlesnakes hole.
You got to pull up a video of a king snake eating a rattlesnake.
I had no fucking idea.
Kingsnakes have a certain protein in their body that diffuses rattlesnake venom
and makes them immune to it.
That's a Predator's Predator right there.
They don't even have teeth,
but they just dash onto a fucking rattlesnake.
Get Ahold of that bitch,
screw them up tight and start swallowing them whole headfirst.
They get ahold of him so fast.
The rattlesnake doesn't even have a chance to bite him.
Clamp a hold of his head and just stretch their mouth out.
Sorry.
I mean the difference being like Joey Diaz eating you like not that much
difference in size,
like not enough where you would go.
How is Joey get David Semen in his whole body?
A book.
But this is like a choice meal for the kingsnakes.
The Joey snake.
Yeah.
Look at this snake.
I mean evil looking motherfucker,
but look at that evil fucker.
You would think.
Now the rattlesnake is a big fat,
evil look and snake.
That's gotta be the key Predator here and this king snake doesn't know what the
hell he's doing.
Boy,
he's going near that rattlesnake.
He's going to get killed and eaten and no,
the rattlesnake eats a bunch of pussy mice.
This is why you can't expect perfection in government does.
This is the alternative.
Look at this like rose,
like we should get back to nature.
We should be more in touch.
This is fucking awful.
Like it's good that we broke free.
Nature's ruthless.
You don't want to get back to nature because nature does give no fucks about
you.
Look at this,
look at this thing.
It gets up to the rattlesnake and it's like,
hi,
how you doing?
Hey,
I've got a question for you.
Um,
do you mind if I get your fucking ass hole?
Look at that.
Clamps a hold of it and runs with it.
Drags his big fat rattlesnakes.
It's the size of it.
Look at the width of the rattlesnake and look at the width of its body.
It's the same size.
Look at that thing.
It's swallowing something that's the same size.
Is it?
That's ambition.
It's ruthless.
It's nature,
right?
Yeah.
Nature's that evil fucking cunt.
While we're on the topic of snakes.
Have you seen that youtube video where the snake charmer is charming the Cobra
and then gets right up to it and kisses it on the head and then backs away?
No.
You gotta watch this cause it's like inspirational.
Yeah,
but you know they take the teeth out of those things.
Is that what it is?
So he doesn't care if it bites him up the same.
You've got to do it with a live one.
There's cool videos of like,
like these really dangerous scary like snakes with babies in the,
and it's just like wrapping around the baby and trying to bite the baby's face
that they tap the baby's forehead with her nose,
with their teeth don't come out because they had him removed.
That's not right.
I'm in fair.
I'm in favor of a fair fight.
Fuck a fair fight,
dude.
You would never have steak.
There was a fair fight.
You would never get a cheeseburger.
Do you understand that if there's fair fights you lose every time,
you're not going to get meat from a bowl.
How even you going to get close?
What's the fair fight fair fight means for every one of them we kill.
They kill one of us.
Fuck man.
We would lay off stake a long time ago you were talking with,
with great passion about your cheeseburger and a beer you had.
Those don't exist.
Look at this snake pop and this little kid in ad.
First of all,
those people are assholes.
Sorry Nicholas.
Why even let kid getting relaxed about being around a fucking snake.
This is like the real life Xbox right here.
This is how it is in some parts of the world.
Yeah.
Look how horrible this is though.
This fucking poor baby.
Like it's getting tapped on the head that things trying to kill him.
That thing is trying to kill that baby.
Whether or not it actually kills that baby.
It's still,
you're letting some heartless,
vicious thing.
Try to kill your baby.
Yeah.
Poke it in the eye.
Just observes him afterwards like,
Huh,
yeah,
but look at this.
It's like trying to grab her.
Oh my God,
that's so disturbing that Oh my God.
And what's crazy is started in the fucking starts wrapping around the babies,
which is,
I don't think it's cool at all because I mean that's still got it.
Well,
I'm glad you took a stand serious,
serious party foul.
But I mean I understand like it's Kinda cute having a snake,
man.
This right here
grabbed it.
Yeah,
and that's when the,
the,
the baby probably got really fucked up and they stopped the video.
That's just wrong man.
You let your baby wrestle a fucking Cobra.
How much do you hate your kids?
Let a Cobra Bite your baby.
If a Cobra even with no teeth bit my baby,
I'd punt that thing to the fucking moon.
It's just tough love.
That's a belt.
That's that thing is a belt.
Sorry,
pair of boots.
You give up your life.
You tried to pick a baby,
right?
So crazy evil.
Fucking creepy.
Fanned out snake asshole.
That's just so goofy.
I don't need to see this anymore,
man.
This is disturbing asshole parents.
Shitty fucking bad.
Snake charmer fucking parents.
David [inaudible]
thinking about it.
He's like,
David,
are you gonna have a baby someday?
Do you want a baby?
I want kids.
I don't want to baby.
You know,
like Ah,
I'm willing to like doesn't work though.
I'm willing to deal with the baby phase,
but that's not what I want.
I want like the foster dad,
big brother,
but I want it to be biologically related to me cause I think that this sounds
really selfish and like full of Shit.
But I think that one of the only ways that we gain in mortality is the fact that
we're allowing part of us to carry on.
And I think it's really cool to think about like,
oh,
I'm part my dad and he's parked his grandfather and that this is the way that we
communicate through thousands.
Severes do you think that that's all I'm going to go away when there's real
genetic manipulation?
Probably.
Yeah.
We're talking about creating an artificial human being that one day there's
going to be when if pal tro is going to like design a child.
We're talking about artificial human beings.
We're talking about the ability to duplicate everything.
When we were talking about that the old man,
the 60 year old man who didn't realize that he never lived a life and then he,
they implanted all these memories in him and he starts crying.
He was like blade runner,
like a replicant Jack like Rutger Hauer like the end when he's just,
he's really almost human and so human that he actually lets Harrison Ford
survive.
He said he's got compassion and he is calculating and totally and when you get
to that point and then
you get to the point where you were able to manipulate genetics and you say,
you know,
hey,
I'm just going to stick with the genetics I've got.
I mean I'm not,
I'm not a,
you don't need to make anything any better and everyone around you is he man,
everyone around you is God damn Madonna's everyone around you is Michael Jordan
in his prime.
Everyone around you is his giant super athlete and you just decide,
I just like being me normal.
Me and we were,
our society breaks down between mods and regs,
like no more racism now it's mods and regs Gatica kind of situation.
Yeah,
like a second.
It's second tier citizen if you're not biologically perfect.
Well it's those,
there's some things that people had contemplated or thought may be the case
someday in the future that have turned out to be real of great example.
We were talking about this yesterday was Ed TV,
that Matthew mcconaughey movie where he played a guy where they just followed a
regular camera and it was a show Truman show kind of know,
but it was a real show.
He knew about the Truman show was the fact that he didn't know about the talent
show,
but that a real show was based on this guy's life.
Just him living his life and everybody wanted to know what he was going to do.
You got to marry the girl,
you're going to get the job,
like what's going to end?
They're following him around with a camera and he becomes famous for no reason.
And then he realized how crazy is and the end,
there's supposed to be some sort of a lesson that we learned.
Nobody thought that would ever,
that you couldn't make that movie today.
Why?
Because that movie is just a reality show and no one's going to buy a movie
about a reality show that's stupid.
Like,
well,
it's like it's some strange thing.
No,
you've got Kim Kardashian,
who's the most famous woman on the planet earth.
She is at TV.
I mean now it's real.
So things like Gatica science fiction,
wow.
Craziness.
Genetically Modified human beings to see the the the modified ones versus the
non modified ones and the elitism of the separation because of resources.
The people that can afford to be perfect and then the rest of the dregs of
society,
they're out there banging at the door trying to get into the fucking spaceship.
That's all coming,
man.
That's,
it's going to happen.
If,
if we stay alive,
it's going to happen.
There's going to be perfect people.
If you don't have enough bitcoins,
you don't get into this space spaceship to Mars via.
It's interesting how like the founding fathers didn't address stuff like digital
privacy or where your metadata should be stored because they could not picture
it.
They had no idea what a smartphone was and that was only a few hundred years or
less than that.
Clinton could have been,
could have saw it coming and so no one saw it coming.
We're also talking about like,
well who owns space?
Who owns the minerals that are on Mars?
These will be ridiculous questions a couple of hundred years ago and I think at
the same way it's going to be like,
well,
should we have fully automated police officer's like should we have the century
in this from uh,
whatever they were the Cylon centurions should we have those things walking our
streets and that's,
those are going to be issues in the next 20 years,
not the next hundred years.
Yeah.
The,
that's a really point about trying to figure out who owns the natural resources
in space because that's probably going to be,
we might even have space wars.
If you think about why humans fight,
it's mostly for resources.
I could totally see like China and the u s duking it out in some kind of
interstellar that could you imagine like if they found that there was a,
um,
an asteroid or something and it has,
you know,
fucking hundred trillion dollars where the oil in it or diamonds or what have
you,
and you could get there in a day's time and then Russia says were gone and the
United States,
it was fuck you were going.
And they tried to Duke it out over who?
They,
they've got to have space wars.
They're flying around shooting rockets at each other in space,
laser beams and shit.
Death Rays,
Star Wars,
the,
the actual military program being used like satellites shooting at space
shuttles where they're on their way.
This asteroid to get diamonds,
it's going to be crazy.
And also a space right now is still mostly government sponsored.
So they think of a specific mission,
like let's go to Mars,
had photographs,
some shit and send back the photos.
And then once that's done,
the mission's over.
But once we get true,
uh,
I hate to sound like I'm,
what's the word?
But once we get like free market enterprise and space,
as cheesy as that sounds,
we're like the motivation never stops.
The mission never stops the mission.
As we got to go further and find more resources.
Once we do that we're going to explore such a large part of,
of space because the money aspect is finally there.
Your rise before it's just like we'll do this because we have to do it.
We have to beat Russia,
but then we're coming home.
You're right.
Wasn't that like the premise of the movie alien?
Weren't they totally releasing?
I think really Scott has the most accurate picture of what the future will look
like.
It's not going to be utopian.
It's not going to be completely awful.
It's just going to be powerful space mining companies.
Uh,
give us the motivation to create really fast spaceships cause we got to get out
there faster to beat other companies and once he had the same competitive drive
that makes your phone so good and you know,
makes all this shit possible,
get that in space.
It's going to be completely insane.
Yeah,
no shit.
Right.
That's really what's going to propel space travel.
They figure out a way to make trillions of dollars by mining asteroids and
things along those lines.
The,
the,
the really Scott versions of alien too with like the most likely scenario of
what the fuck would happen if something got to us.
Like something that breeds as quickly as a disease,
something that grows to a gigantic size really quickly.
Like all of our biological limitations that we sort of put on bodies and aliens
and what,
what,
what would a body looked like if it came from space?
It probably looked like a fucking spider.
Like alien.
What is alien?
It's a giant spider and they can't reason with that thing and tell it like,
don't be a Predator and eat everybody on the space ship.
It's the same as like a,
you talking about sharks.
That's something that was developed in the same system as us.
And we can't even convince a shark not to eat us.
Think about when you're facing the thing with the mouth coming out of it,
you know,
the multiple
mouths,
it was going to be no way to stop,
whatever.
Uh,
what was the other movie that was kind of like that?
Um,
with Harrison Ford,
that movie that came out recently,
recently,
and there's gamers game yet.
I didn't see that.
Was that any good?
I thought it was pretty good.
Yeah.
But they go after this like insect race and it's hard for them to communicate
and figure out what that race,
his intentions are because they're so alien,
you know?
It's like they're talking to like human sized ants basically.
Oh,
that's cool.
We can't even figure out what the fuck orchids are saying.
And you swim on top of them.
They ride those motherfuckers and we can't figure out what they're saying.
You know,
they don't know what dolphins are saying.
They know when they're upset.
That's it.
You know,
they know when they're happy,
but they're here and we've been studying them for decades.
We don't know shit.
You know,
there's no like dolphin decoder device where we are and it comes out like,
you know,
yeah,
Google text.
David Brennan has this really interesting idea.
I think he calls it uplifting and it's,
I don't know if he actually believes this or if it was like something he wrote
in a science fiction book,
but it's a really cool idea and it's that at some point we're going to look to
other species on the earth that we find to be interesting,
probably dogs and dolphins and stuff and we're like,
we're going to upgrade.
You were going to figure out a way for us to communicate directly because you're
very similar to us and you probably have a,
you know,
a perspective that's different from the human perspective,
so we're going to elevate them to our level.
Whereas right now they're kind of like savages.
We're going to bring them into modern society and kind of coexist with these
other species in a way that we've never done before.
Wow.
Well that is what they,
when you get to the real nutty people,
thank that human beings were engineered by aliens.
That's essentially the premise of the last one.
Promethium yeah,
the engineer,
you know that is the premise.
The premise is that human beings were in some way or form designed by something
more intelligent.
They decided to bring us up a little bit.
That engineer was such a Dick.
It's smart enough to create the human race but just flips out and starts like
killing people.
Stupid movie.
That movie sucked.
It was cool.
It was okay.
I'm science fiction,
it's fun.
I enjoy those movies.
But
it wasn't,
the first one was so god damn good.
And then the second one was pretty fucking good and the third one was not very
good.
And then the fourth one was not good.
And then this one was,
oh man,
he spent a lot of money on this.
Did you talk to any geeks need to talk to Geeks,
get a real fucking science fiction geek and ask him what's wrong with this
movie?
And he'll tell you like,
why is he freaking out?
Why is this super smart giant dude roiling out
and they have this huge like hologram version of the universe.
They have to like see it all.
I can three dimensional flying through space.
Is that just because you wanted to use that technology,
but that's an inefficient way of mapping out the unit.
The Universe is infinite.
We can have an infinite
map up there and the fucking sky.
He would just have a tablet and hit earth done.
Yeah.
No need for all this stuff.
Good.
Take me to Miami.
Boom.
Did you watch the blood moon?
That was a true,
yeah.
It was weird.
Yeah.
How often does that happen?
I don't even know exactly what the blood moon is that just the regular clips?
It's a,
it's an eclipse,
but there's something that happens where it looks red for will kill.
Let's find out three or four years.
There's an eclipse,
but I'm not sure about the blood moon part,
but the weird thing is when it got to that orange ish reddish phase,
it literally looked like somebody just throw a ball and it was just floating
there like it didn't look like the moon because the lighting,
especially when it started hitting the,
the left side really make,
you never saw lighting come from the bottom.
Like that just made the whole moon look fake as fuck.
Yeah.
There's a cool thing on CNN where they have all the various images of it and
they have some people did like time lapses and it's an interesting and the time
lapse you see like when it's in certain parts of the sky,
it's totally white and then it gets to one small segment of the sky where
there's some sort of a reflection or something and that is what's causing it.
If rain clouds rain or clouds obscured your lunar experience,
don't fret.
This episode is one of the first four consecutive total lunar eclipse is known
as a Tetrad that will occur in a six month interval,
uh,
until September of 2015 wow.
Unlike solar eclipses,
lunar eclipses are safe to view with the naked eye and don't require special
filters,
so it's a part of the eclipse,
a process
that right there when you saw that chartering photo part happened,
it's like,
all right,
this is not the moon.
What the fuck is this thing?
It's creepy.
It's almost like it's a semi-transparent.
It's pretty cool.
Some,
a guy has this really wacky youtube page that I just found out about and it's
interesting when you go to someone's youtube page and you find out that they
have,
like every video has like 2 million plus views.
I'm like,
this is nuts.
This guy's insane amount of views and it's sort of a science based one.
It's kind of cool that it has so many views because it's a really intelligent
youtube page.
Someone was asking me to have the guy on the podcast and I had never heard of
the guy,
so I go to his page.
I was like,
what?
Yeah.
One of them was,
what if the moon was a giant disco ball and what if the moon was a disco ball
and it was only 300 miles from the earth's surface?
It was like floating right about what would it look like?
So they did this animated thing of what the moon would look like.
As a typical Paul that's 300 miles away,
it's insane.
We've fills up the whole night sky.
Like you realize how big the moon really is and you're like,
oh my God.
Like when you see this graphic representation of it filling up the night sky.
It's a really cool idea that they try to do that.
I mean it wouldn't,
I don't put it up,
Christ go over this.
How many times we have to go over this.
Um,
it's the,
the,
the size of
it though,
in relationship to the earth and you really get an idea of the one quarter of
the size of the earth.
Like that's how big the moon actually is.
This is one of the way the fuck up.
There's this little tiny thing,
but if it was floating in our sky,
it would literally take up the entire night's guy that,
that space show.
Man,
I'm so addicted to cosmos,
Cosmos.
That's awesome.
It's so awesome.
Well,
Seth Mcfarlane's a bad motherfucker and Neil degrasse Tyson is also a bad
motherfucker is he'll be on,
hopefully I'll get them on this month.
He's around.
He's just back and forth.
We've been emailing each other.
He's,
he's busy as fuck.
I hope it does.
Well,
I don't know what the ratings are of it,
but I was,
I was wondering why I was watching it.
Is there anything
good?
It's really good.
And what's really cool is that it's on like Hulu and stuff like that so you can
just watch it straight up.
Got to cross,
cross promoted with like duck hunter.
Oh there's some stupid fucking shows on discovery channel man.
I went to discovery the other day and I was like,
how did discovery becomes
this?
All of them.
The TLC is now like nothing to do with learning.
It's,
it's the uh,
honey booboo channel now.
And discovery has these shows that have nothing to do with discovering anything.
Now if you want what discovery used to be,
you got to head over to science channel and then you get how,
uh,
how it's made is one of my favorite shows to watch wall show while I'm enjoying
a certain substances because it gives,
it gives you an appreciation for everything.
Like something boring.
Like this bottle of water becomes fascinating.
Yeah.
How it's made is a really cool show.
It's disturbing though.
Looking at,
there's a new show on,
um,
on discovery.
You remember that video that we played at Ted Nugent and this guy,
pig man shooting a pigs from a helicopter,
just machine gunning pigs out of a helicopter.
These wild feral pigs,
they have to eradicate from a lot of these Texas farms.
Well now he's got his own show.
Pig Man has his own show.
It's called boss hog and on boss Hog,
he's a running around.
He owns a barbecue place that cooks up these pigs that he shoots and him and his
dad run around shooting pigs.
And then they have a lot of fake scenarios that take place because they're,
they're obviously artificially scripted scenarios,
arrows.
And because that shows,
it shows you that we're animals still and we're starting to accept that.
I don't think it is entirely bad that we're going to stupid or programming
because you're not stupid or,
but things that have the discovery channel to do the science because we're like,
oh,
we like to watch people hunt.
We like to watch people negotiate.
And that's pawn stars.
Fuck.
Like,
we're just interested in seeing other humans do all these things that we have to
do,
but their logo has a fucking planet in it.
I mean,
the discovery channel,
it's like you thinking about like,
oh,
we're going to watch a documentary around polar bears.
Yeah,
we're going to see leopard seals.
Yeah.
You're not as second to discover anything.
Discover the back of a fucking pawn shop.
I'll show you that.
I made some barbecue.
Woo.
We're gonna sell moonshot.
We're crazy.
That cop doesn't even see the camera.
Look out one normal.
Jakks well,
it's the truck.
What's in the truck?
Why is there a camera pointed at you in a fucking crew?
Why is your microphones on everybody?
How about that question?
That Mermaid Shit.
All that up.
That's like creepy videos.
Perfect example.
That animal planet made a fake fucking show on mermaids.
Like a fake.
Who pretended that there were real mermaids and they knew they were trolling the
whole time.
You want me?
Tommy's sent me fucking tweets through thrown real mermaids.
No,
no,
they didn't.
No,
they didn't find real mermaids.
I'm about to actually cancel my cable this week.
I think,
I think I've got Internet.
I've been trying to just do a soft cancel where I act like I don't have it and I
just go on Netflix.
Go on Hulu.
Hulu is the best man between
Netflix and Amazon video.
There's no reason to really have cable except for like when there's a live event
that you can just get a,
I think you can pay,
um,
so kind of small fee for CNN live and then you're good.
You know?
Well,
you know,
I don't want to recommend bit torrent,
but you're all,
there's a way to get things and the most bit torrented show ever in the history
of bit torrent is the most recent episode of game of Thrones.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a bit torrent by some insane number.
I think it was 200,000 different people had it available for downloading,
which is amazing.
Here it is.
The winner for the largest bit torrent swarm ever 193,000 pirates simultaneously
sharing the same file.
I love the language that we use for the swarm of pirates is the biggest ever had
eye patches and hooks it fucking beat their keyboard with the hook.
Actually never use that anymore.
I stopped it.
I used to too scary,
too dangerous.
Too many people just getting the fuck suit out of him for for seeding.
You know you have it up there and you know you're,
you know,
having people and then they fucking send software that infects your computer and
now you don't even know that you're hacked.
And it's just crazy.
The,
the fees that some people like some housewife,
you owe us $1 million.
What the,
the nonsense behind it ones and Zeros.
Bitch.
I wonder if game of Thrones does anything about this,
if they,
if they'd go after it,
if they try to stop it.
Definitely during an August earnings call with investors,
Time Warner CEO Jeff Bewkes bragged about the shows of massive piracy levels.
It says,
if you go around the world,
I think you're right.
Game of Thrones is the most pirated show in the world.
He said,
now that's better than an Emmy.
Huh?
Wow.
That's what,
that's a good attitude.
It's really enlightened.
I like that.
That is a good attitude because look,
it's not going to stop people from watching it.
And it does expose your,
if people like it,
they will go pay money for the movie version.
They will pay money for the book that you get some kind of royalty on.
You know,
like there's ways to make money.
Uh,
HBO CEO doesn't care that you are sharing your HBO.
What's his password?
Then I watched his HBO go,
we're in the business of creating addicts.
He said,
oh,
that's a great attitude.
That's a great attitude.
And you know what,
if people can afford HBO,
they're going to get HBO,
right?
If you can afford it,
and if you can't,
you're not going to get it.
So like this idea that you're stopping people,
you're stealing money,
are they really or are they simply getting something and enjoying it that they
would've never been able to afford?
There's going to be a bunch of people that,
yeah,
they would have been forced to pay for it,
but I bet it evens itself out.
I bet.
In a long run,
it kind of evens itself out one way or another because people are going to get
HBO.
The music business got fucked.
The music business,
without a doubt,
that shit disappeared.
They went the dumb way.
They like,
this is a,
I swear this is the last time I mentioned digital money,
but banks have an opportunity to not do the exact same thing that record
companies did was like,
Oh shit,
we got to fight this tooth and nail.
All it leads to is better technology and the second version you can't fight.
Whereas the first version you can and it doesn't stop human behavior.
It just makes you irrelevant.
Okay.
If they brought you into a meeting,
say like Bank of America says David Seaman,
we liked the way you think.
We heard you on the Joe Rogan experience.
You've got some great ideas.
What should we do?
What should we do is digital?
You know,
I'm,
I don't even have email.
Okay.
Hey,
you know,
I got to go like to go duck hunting on the weekends.
Yeah.
What should I do?
It's very simple.
If you're,
if somebody called me in for a meeting like that,
it's a,
it all comes down to game theory and it's like we have this thing in the middle
of the table that everybody wants and at the earliest adopters would benefit
from.
So you as bank of America or you as chase,
you want to be the first one new adopt this because you're going to gain so much
market share so fast that it's going to fuck all your competitors and people
right now are desperate for a bit coin service they can trust and is as Shitty
as these banks are.
The Bank of America brand name has a lot more trust then that Guy Karplus.
Right.
So like between those two organizations,
who would I prefer to have my bitcoin with or who would rather,
who would I prefer to buy it with?
Definitely the bank that's down the street and that I know has,
you know whatever market cap they have,
they have a lot of money and I know they're not going under tomorrow.
So I would say ignore all the political rabble rousing and all the bold
predictions people like me are making,
which will probably not come true.
And instead look at this as just the better technology and you as a bank,
you want to implement better technologies cause it means lower fraud,
less expense,
more possibility for profit and innovation.
Go fucking do it and do it before chased us.
That's a really good piece of advice right there.
I like to rephrase that too,
that there is an uh,
you've built up a name,
there's a lot of trust in your name and you can monopolize it.
It's like this is what people want now.
Like you didn't decide it and maybe it's to your short term disadvantage,
but people want something and that's a good thing.
It's almost like a,
you remember the social network where the one guy wanted him to put ads all over
the site and he's like,
no,
like we don't know what this is,
but we know it's cool right now and banks have not done anything cool in a very
long time and the young people are really disenfranchised.
I hate most banks and it's because they've been so bad and they just do a bad
job with what they do.
If you modernize a little bit,
you might get the 20 and 30 somethings to put their money back in your bank,
you might make a lot of money.
That's a really good point,
man.
It's a really good point and it's also about addressing the inevitability of
what's going on like,
but they would look at it in terms of maybe they have their finger on the
trigger that,
but they don't want to press it too soon and fucked themselves.
It's like when you heard that like a RJ Reynolds had the patents for several
different strains of marijuana and they had labels printed up ready to go.
That was always one of those urban myths,
you know?
But the idea was that they don't want to come out with it too soon because of
marijuana does become legal.
They want to be able to jump on it and be able to sell.
That's,
that's the pope called gold.
That's weakness right there.
Because we never control when things happen,
but we control how we respond.
And I think Amazon is run by a brilliant guy and I think their failure to accept
bitcoin is one of their first really big fuckups because overstock is a big
company too.
And they're going to get a lot bigger because now there's that loyalty there.
Before I didn't care about overstock at all.
I mean,
I would never mention them on a show like yours.
Overstock,
it's like some bullshit ecommerce site.
It's a ecommerce site.
And up until recently I would not care at all.
I'm like,
who cares about this second tier e commerce site?
But now to me,
they're like the new Amazon cause they get it.
And so I can see them,
uh,
gaining what Amazon would have if they had jumped in.
What is the difference?
What does,
I'm not aware of.
Overstock?
Uh,
it's just you.
Do you know what it is?
Brian overstock the big,
oh,
what is it?
The ads you see much.
What is overstock?
Yeah,
it's uh,
it's pretty much where they take older stuff where they have too much like a
iPads.
Right?
They bought too many iPads.
There is a new iPad about to come out.
So overstock,
we'll buy all those old iPads for a cheaper price,
you know,
cause there's too much stock.
Like it's not selling.
Oh I see.
So it's kind of like Ross for electronics.
You get new.
Anything new there?
Yeah,
you can get new stuff.
Pasta.
But a lot of it,
I mean it's at least the original,
uh,
how it started off was always like too much stuff.
That's nice.
I think that was the way that they started and took off was that they offer
cheaper stuff because it was literally overstock.
But now you can get pretty much anything.
So what's the difference between their model of business and Amazon's you think
their model of business is superior?
Uh,
I just think the CEO is able to,
to look into the future better than what Amazon is doing because Amazon is
playing it safe.
And if you're,
if you're that kind of company,
you can't afford to play it safe.
And that's one of the reasons why Google is doing so well is they go like,
we'll spend a lot of money on crazy stuff that will not work out.
And that's okay because one of those crazy things might be our next major
revenue stream.
And that's happened several times.
You know,
Gmail started is we're just going to offer free email and see where it goes.
Now.
It's a huge source of revenue.
Give an example,
like,
I don't understand what you're saying.
Like how are they,
how are they doing?
How are they doing it smarter ways and what does Amazon doing it where they're
playing it?
Oh,
it have been doing overstock bitcoin.
so Amazon CEO just said that,
that he,
uh,
reason why he doesn't do bitcoins because there's not enough need for it.
And I guess,
you know,
incorporating bitcoin into,
it's probably gonna cost a lot of money.
It's probably a good,
this big deal.
But,
but he's saying there's not enough demand for it.
We're going to talk to,
uh,
um,
our pal,
Alexis,
like,
no,
not Ohanian Andress Andreas Antonopoulos next week on the 22nd.
He is a true bitcoin expert.
I'm not an expert,
I'm just somebody who likes it like it went to Nepalis is the bitcoin Jesus.
He's,
I mean he gets all of his money from bitcoin.
He doesn't take money anymore.
He gets paid in Bitcoin.
He does all of exchanges in bit coins.
He buys food in bitcoins.
I Dunno,
he does that.
Yeah.
I don't do that shit when I'm out on a date I'm at like,
oh,
can I print out a paper wallet and then we'll,
we'll transact.
You know like I just pay with a credit card done.
Overstocks Deli.
Yeah.
You don't want to like,
let a chick think you're weird.
Like that would be like the deal breaker.
He tried to pay in Bitcoin.
Although I gotta say women,
I want to give a shout out to women in La.
I to give a shout out to all the ladies.
All the ladies out there,
especially in La,
keeping your toes pretty,
they're like the polar opposite of the guy on pawn stars.
I was thinking about this like that guys like best I can do is 20 bucks and La
and again,
this is not like I haven't sampled like the whole population,
but uh,
they're like,
I don't know you all that well best I can do as a blowjob and sex on a second
date and you're like really shit like that.
Good.
Uh,
women out here in much nicer than the east coast really?
That's been,
or when I say the East Coast Palm about South Florida,
there's a lot of difficult women in south Florida.
Difficult,
just not friendly.
Like,
and I've had to blow on you man.
I've had this conversation with friends of mine who still live on the east coast
and they're like,
you don't like dude,
you're just dealing with superficial chicks and you think they're friendly.
I'm like,
I like the superficiality.
What's wrong man?
What's wrong with manners?
What's wrong with giving me your phone number and saying,
yeah,
I'd love to go out next week and of like,
fuck you.
You know,
like is that what you got in Florida?
Fuck,
you'll you get really a,
you don't know if an interaction is going to turn out well or if it's going to
be like the spider video.
That's what you get in Miami is there's something,
uh,
about the culture there where it's like kind of fun the shoot down guys and
here,
like everybody just treats people like people and I like,
oh,
it's one of those things.
Yeah.
The fun shooting down guys thing like this is a sport.
There is a thrill to it.
They get all dressed up and you're like Horny as fuck and they just shoot you
down in front of everybody and you don't see that happening as much out here.
And I think maybe it's just the culture.
Maybe it's the weed,
I don't know what it is.
Maybe it's a reflection of David seaman getting a little bit of Internet
celebrity,
getting some pussy and starting to judge a patch of dirt differently.
I fucking,
California is where it's at.
People are blowing me back in Florida.
They're just angry,
walkaway hot and screaming at me.
But now look at you.
That was an intense shout out.
It was intense.
You want to give a shout out to Joe's
cat cause he has the coolest eyes.
Is that your cat?
That's Prince.
All right.
Who is that?
A Siamese or something.
Now he's a rag doll.
Ragdoll rag doll cat is a,
um,
there were like real sweet,
like you pick them up,
they go limp.
They kind of go rag doll on you.
That's the idea behind,
uh,
the name.
I think he's awesome.
Cool cat.
Cool.
Yeah.
Well I started letting them outside recently.
I used to worry about them because there's hawks in the neighborhood and owls.
Owls are a big one,
especially at night.
Owls kill cats all the time and uh,
you really have to watch it because there's an owl that lives in my neighborhood
and he's fucking huge.
It's really big.
I mean,
I'm not joking.
It's a body of it is like that big.
Apply your hunting skills and get rid of that threat.
No,
you can't do that.
You can't.
No,
you shouldn't do that.
You can't do that.
I was a really necessary,
they keep the rat population down.
Plus,
if you kill an hour,
the Illuminati will probably come after you because of Moloch the owl.
I was in Bohemian Grove,
I saw Moloch
the,
here's the,
here's the thing about Bohemian Grove,
not knowing much about it,
but if you're a billionaire,
there are very few people that you can relate to who aren't immediately like
immediately like a,
here's my job resume.
Like what can you do for me?
It's a very weird situation to be in,
so you don't want people scamming you and you want to talk business and you want
to also relax.
Yeah.
Aren't you going to meet somewhere and like talk some shit out and nonpublic
place?
Yeah.
With an owl.
God mask on and fucking,
and maybe,
maybe you all just out on a dog.
Maybe you all,
how do you have a pet out?
That's a weird half an hour as a pet.
I don't know,
man.
The owl that's in my neighborhood,
no bullshit.
Twice as big as that goddamn thing.
It's huge.
It's sat on my back fence the other day.
I looked at it,
I was like,
wow,
it's a surveillance devices.
We probably weighs 30 pounds.
It's fucking huge.
And I saw one of them with a flow.
It was flying with a rabbit in its claws.
I was like,
I was watching some prehistoric shit.
It was really weird flying,
holding onto a rabbit.
Ooh,
give a hoot.
Don't pull it.
Birds are weird because they're definitely smart.
There are lizards.
Yeah.
They lacked the any kind of uh,
relate-ability like a dog.
It understands you.
You understand it.
A bird.
You're like,
what is this thing thinking?
But you know,
it's smart
there.
They have intelligence.
We'll crows have unbelievable intelligence.
I know you've seen some of those videos were crows problem solve and use tools
and not just use tools,
but use multiple step tools,
like one tool to get to another tool.
They use that tool to get to a third tool.
Then you that tool to get to meet.
I mean,
it's incredible.
If you've seen,
if you've seen any of these videos.
No.
You have to watch one.
It'll fucking blow you away.
Can we get,
we can't get pulled from youtube by using a youtube clip,
right?
That we can't get.
Can we
fuck motherfuckers pulling us off youtube left and right.
Um,
see if you can find just one clip on cro intelligence.
We've had this on the podcast,
but it's so fascinating.
I watched that shit over and over again and then we'll get the fuck outta here.
Finding Cro,
cro intelligence,
using problem solving tools.
Just Google all that shit.
Crozer apparently as smart if not smarter than chimpanzees.
How is that possible?
It has such a small brain compared to the chimp brain.
I don't know.
Remember you went for 12 years.
Your faith for something stupid.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But watch this year put to give it some volume.
Not very much.
Fine.
Oh my God.
Oh Jesus.
What are you doing?
I don't know.
This is not on,
but it is.
There is volume.
This cro,
so it takes this one twig and then makes these socks,
this second twig to go over to this thing and pull this meat towards it.
Wow.
And then eats it.
That's definitely like monkey intelligence.
So it took one twig to get to a second twig and then took that second twig and
went,
I mean it couldn't reach the first twig without using or the second trig without
using the first wig is unbelievable.
There's thinking ahead use of tools.
That's just two.
There's one that where it shows three different steps,
like uses one tool to get to a second tool to get to a second.
Too bad they're so ugly.
Or people would have them as pets.
Why don't think they would tolerate you?
I think so.
Yeah.
I think they're wild.
I think there's certain animals you just not going to figure out.
Like,
you know,
they tried to tame zebras at one point in time.
All these assholes that moved to the Congo and built the states and tried to
fucking enslave people and run things in Africa and then I'll never worked.
One of the things they tried to do is they try to domesticate zebras.
He can't do it.
Why can't you domesticate a zebra?
They will tolerate.
So here's a five step.
Wait,
look at this.
Watch it takes,
I mean,
this is incredible.
It takes one tool and then it goes over and can't get,
this tool is trying real hard to get this tool.
He goes,
hmm,
let me see what the fuck we do here.
He gets a second tool.
Okay.
Uses that tool to go.
It tries to get the beat,
can't do it.
Tried to get the third tool so it uses this one to get to this one.
Now he's got another tool then takes that fucking tool,
spins it around.
So the other part like the part that has like the little hook on the end of it,
he's like trying to get the meat,
can't get it.
Alrighty.
And there he goes.
That is true intelligence.
That's smarter than like 90% of the people I've dealt with.
The DMV.
Yeah.
It's all of the people at the DMV.
How about that?
I said it,
I can to see if your registration gets renewed on time.
Yeah.
You put those people in that room,
would that crow,
the crow would figure that shit out.
Queer.
Yeah.
I don't know how intelligence works and obviously they don't have a language,
so maybe they're not as hampered by a lot of and insecurities and a lot of weird
shit that the human brain harbors like maybe a lot of what runs us is just
nonsense and Hawaii.
How much time has everybody spent thinking about things that have never had like
not come to pass like fears that are just a waste of energy?
Probably a fuck load,
right?
Yeah.
I'm just thinking about my own life and like it's always the thing that you're
not thinking about that ends up getting you like an asteroid.
Yeah.
Again,
asteroids like,
oh,
we didn't prepare for that one at all.
Or if Fukushima,
nobody was preparing for that.
David Moore do.
Can't end on doom and gloom.
Pretty smart.
Just Sheryl Crow is probably not as smart as a CHRO as far as like problem
solving.
If you got Sheryl Crow and the crow and neither one of them had any idea what
was going on that you made them do those two things,
we can end on a positive note.
I think,
uh,
despite the minor negative stuff,
this has been really positive.
Like the whole financial system is going to change it the next five years and
it's going to swing in a direction where individuals have more power and banks
have less.
I mean,
that's cool.
It's really cool actually.
And I talked to Stefan Molyneux early this week and I asked him,
I was like,
am I diluted by telling people like this is going to change everything?
And he's like,
no,
I think that it's going to change a lot of stuff.
And he was telling me about how it's going to change politics in a big way
because you just,
you can't get bribes with bitcoin basically.
Like banks can't bribe you.
You can't bribe them back by,
uh,
um,
propping them up the next time they need a bail out.
This whole thinking of like a bank just spends money and pretty much makes risky
bets and derivatives and stuff.
And then when those bets,
uh,
go south,
they get a bail out from the government and get taxpayer money,
that craziness will go away.
It's going to be,
oh,
how many bitcoins do you have?
Oh,
okay.
I see.
Cool.
So it's good.
You know,
it actually goes back to ancient times where a,
in places like Mesopotamia,
when merchants would do business,
they didn't need to chase or bank of America,
they just had like merchant ledgers,
like,
oh,
I see.
I owe you 15 cattle.
Very good.
And you decide on a standard and you go with that.
And the whole world might do that now.
And it's happening already.
When I say it might happen,
there's a reason why is at $500 each,
and that's because in China where they have a radically different government
from hours,
far more oppressive,
they don't speak the same language,
they don't have the same culture,
they're interested in the same currency and that's really cool.
And bitcoin,
is it more popular in any parts of the world besides America?
It's more popular in China,
I believe.
I believe most of the,
I might be wrong,
but I think most of the trading volume right now is in China.
But definitely most of the startups are in Silicon Valley.
Wonder what steps will ask,
um,
Antonopoulos next week,
what steps they've taken to ensure that the same jackals that have gotten a hold
of the financial system and twisted it into this weird cryptic world of
derivatives on the unexplainable things.
If they've done anything to prevent that from happening to things like Bitcoin,
I'm sure if there's a way to corrupted or make it less fun,
they will
do that or they will try for their own profit.
Yeah.
All right man.
Listen,
always fun talking to you.
Definitely.
We've got to do this more often,
which was always cool.
Shit to talk about.
Never run out.
And uh,
again,
we're at a strange time in life.
We're,
we're,
we're right there at the peak of the weirdest way.
The world is RC negative because the technology thing like yeah,
it's bad at the NSA is collecting our stuff and I think that that system is
going to eat itself over time.
Like we have the FBI spying on the CIA and the NSA or rather the CIA.
So I fucked that up.
We have the FBI spying on the CIA and the CIA is spying on the Senate
intelligence committee that's supposed to be overseeing the CIA.
So all these people are spying on each other.
Uh,
stepping on each other's toes.
And I think eventually is going to happen is it's not people like you and me who
will demand reform.
It's people in the Senate who were like,
I don't want my shit spied on anymore.
This is not good.
And they're all going to agree like we need some kind of rollback that'll
happen.
And then we have,
we still have all this amazing technology.
It's moving faster than we can even think about.
And uh,
it's mostly good here,
here,
David Seaman here,
d underscore semen on Twitter.
Um,
your podcast,
the David Seaman hour and it's available.
It's on iTunes and stitcher.
Is there a website,
David seaman.com and we say iTunes and Stitcher,
is it also available as an MP3?
Can they just download it if they have like a zoom,
if they want to go to David seaman.com they can get the link to the NPS p
three.
Yes,
that's it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it for this week.
I'll see you fucking savages in Orlando this Thursday night with Joey Coco Diaz
and I'll see you guys tonight at the Ice House in Pasadena with Ari Shaffir,
Duncan Trussell and young Tony Hinchcliffe.
Thank you to dollar shave.
Go to the dollar shave club,
bitches,
dollar shave club.com forward slash.
Rogan.
Save Time,
save money,
shave time,
shave money.
See what they did.
Their dollar shave club.com forward slash Rogen Gentlemen,
gentlemen ass wipes support the podcast and a great company that has awesome
things including great ways to wipe your butt.
Dollar Shave club.com forward slash.
Rogen.
Thanks also to,
that was the right,
right,
right.
This Rogan Ford.
Slash.
Rogen.
I don't want to give you the wrong URL.
Yeah,
that's it.
Thanks.
Also to ting,
go to rogan.ting.com to get some awesome cell phone service and 25 bucks off
your first device.
That's rogan.ting.com thanks.
Also to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Um,
next week.
Lots of good podcast material going on.
As I said,
ah,
Andreus Antonopoulos coming.
Ace freely is going to be here next week.
I had to move David,
tell the 29th,
David tells going to be on Tuesday the 29th.
I got a lot of shit happening next week and we're going to have some fun.
I'm also coming onto the podcast very soon is uh,
um,
Steve Maxwell,
my friend,
that strength and conditioning coach.
He's a fascinating guy.
Really,
really interesting dude with a lot of knowledge.
He'll be on the 28th.
I've got a lot of stuff happening.
Greg Fitzsimmons on May 1st.
Lots of shit happening.
All right.
We'll see you people later,
soon.
Someday in the future,
uh,
until then keep your shit together.
Bitches big kiss.